foreign
did you know that the market for cloud
computing is expected to reach 832.1
billion dollars by 2025
with the compound annual growth rate of
17.5 percent according to a report by
markets and markets
this situation highlights the rising
demand for cloud engineers in fact
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics IT projects a growth rate of
13 from 2020 to 2030.
but how to take advantage of this golden
opportunity how to become a successful
Cloud engineer
well to help you with this situation and
give you a Clarity on how you can plan
your way to become a successful Cloud
engineer simply learn has brought you a
new video on cloud engineer roadmap to
help you build your career as a cloud
engineer also if you want to upskill
yourself in cloud computing from Basics
to Advanced then you can definitely
check out our course on cloud architect
it will help you build your base in
cloud computing moving on let's have a
look at what you are going to expect or
explore in this video first you will
learn about what is cloud computing
following that you will understand who
is a cloud engineer then you will
explore what all skills are required for
you to become a cloud engineer and what
rules and responsibilities you will hold
then you will go through the cloud
engineer roadmap and what salary you can
expect as a cloud engineer then you will
have a look at all the companies hiring
Cloud engineers and at the end of this
video you will come across cloud
computing interview questions and
answers to help you with bagging a great
interview and an amazing job so let's
get started with the video but before
that do subscribe to our YouTube channel
for more such interesting videos and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn the first thing we
will come across is what is cloud
computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
Computing Services via the Internet
or the cloud including servers storage
databases networking software analytics
and intelligence to provide faster
Innovation more flexible resources and
economies of scale
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost run your infrastructure more
efficiently and scale as your business
grows
that brings us to who is a cloud
engineer
Cloud Engineers are the I.T experts in
charge of accessing an organization's
technology infrastructure and
transferring operations and procedures
to a cloud-based architecture
they assist with the migration of
critical corporate applications and
processes to private public and hybrid
Cloud environments
a cloud engineer's job is to access a
company's ID infrastructure and migrate
certain processes and operations to the
cloud
public private and hybrid cloud
computing systems are among these
functions and operations
now that we know who a cloud engineer is
let's have a look at the skills required
to become one
Cloud Engineers must have a diverse set
of technical talents that they will use
in a variety of positions
several key skill sets that cloud
Engineers need to be successful include
the ability to program and code
cloud-based applications and processes
the ability to troubleshoot technical
challenges through problem solving
the ability to plan and design software
and Cloud applications using critical
and creative thinking
should also include data analysis skills
and should be able to strategically plan
and to fulfill projects using Technical
Resources
now let's have a look at the roles and
responsibilities of cloud engineer
there are three types of cloud engineers
in particular in a small business one
individual may be in charge of all three
roles
Cloud architect
Cloud software engineer and Cloud
security engineer
Cloud architect and organizations cloud
computing strategy include application
design management and monitoring is
overseen by a cloud architect
Cloud Architects connect various aspects
of cloud computing including data and
networks with tools and services
Cloud software engineer a cloud software
engineer create software for cloud
computing systems and isn't in charge of
managing their development and
maintenance
Cloud security engineer control based
Technologies and procedures that enable
Regulatory Compliance regulations are
included in security
when dealing with the cloud the major
purpose is to protect information data
data applications and the infrastructure
now let's focus on the roadmap to become
a cloud engineer
Cloud Engineers generally begin their
careers with a four-year degree in
computer technology
and the steps below defined fundamental
part to becoming a cloud engineer
opt-in a bachelor's degree
in software and systems infrastructure
Computing or other technical areas
your bachelor's degree program should
emphasize software and system
infrastructure Computing and other
technical courses
a bachelor's degree in a computer or
technology related field will also
qualify you for advanced degrees if you
choose to pursue them
learn programming languages python C
plus plus Java and Ruby for example are
great options to start with
aside from programming languages you'll
want to brush up on your Knowledge and
Skills with some of the most popular
cloud services including AWS Hadoop and
azure
it's important that you gain experience
in cloud computing why internships and
open source projects
this will help you build a portfolio of
work that you can use to demonstrate
your competence in future job interviews
it will also teach you vital skills that
you'll need to need on job
consider a master's degree to enhance
your cloud computing abilities while
also advancing your career because of
their higher level of Education Cloud
Engineers with a master's degree in a
tech subject may have additional career
prospects a master's degree in software
engineering a system engineering for
example will help you develop more of
these technical abilities and expertise
advancing your career
get cloud computing certification
to demonstrate your understanding and
skill level in Cloud engineering you can
also check out our official website for
cloud computing certification
it will help you enhance your knowledge
in this particular field
now that we know everything about cloud
computing and how to become a cloud
engineer let's have a quick look at the
average salary of a cloud engineer in
India and in the USA
in India the average salary of a cloud
engineer is rupees 12 lakh 41 000 per
annum
and in the USA the average salary of a
cloud engineer is
837 dollars per annum
now Cloud Engineers may earn a
substantial income with a national
average salary but it can vary though
depending on your location and how many
years you have been in the field for
example a cloud engineer with a master's
degree and several years of experience
may make more than a new graduate with a
four-year degree who is just starting
out in their career
now let's dive down and explore the
company's hiring Cloud engineers
cloud computing is gradually
establishing itself as the industry
standard for data storage and
administration by 2022 according to IDC
over a million cloud computing jobs
would be generated in India Amazon IBM
Wipro Infosys Oracle Cisco these are the
few top companies who are some of the
top Recruiters in this field hi there
I'm Samuel and I'm here to walk you
through some of the AWS interview
questions which we find are important
and our hope is that you would use this
material in your interview preparation
and be able to crack that cloud
interview and step into your dream Cloud
job by the way I'm and Cloud technical
architect trainer and an interview
panelist for cloud Network and devops so
as you progress in watching you're gonna
see that these questions are practically
scenario based questions that tests the
depth of the knowledge of a person in a
particular AWS product or in a
particular AWS architecture so why wait
let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the AWS products that are
built based on them see here it's very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application this basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as Advanced Services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about Basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the question says
explain some of the AWS products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is Lambda
Auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services so the compute
domain it really helps us to run any
application and the compute service
helps us in managing the scaling and
deployment of an application again
Lambda is a compute service so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are S3
object storage
pressure for archiving EBS elastic block
storage as a drive attachment for the
ec2 instances and the EFS file share for
the ec2 instances so the storage domain
helps in the following aspects it holds
all the information that the application
uses so it's the application data and we
can also archive old data using storage
which would be Glacier and any object
files and any requirement for Block
storage can be met through elastic blog
store and S3 which is again an object
storage talking about networks it's just
not important to answer the question
with the name of the services and the
name of the product it'll also be good
if you could go in depth and explain how
they can be used all right so that
actually proves you to be a person
knowledgeable enough in that particular
service or product so so talking about
networking domain VPC networking can't
imagine networking without VPC in in the
cloud environment especially in AWS
Cloud environment and then we have Route
53 for domain resolution or for DNS and
then we have cloudfront which is an edge
caching service that helps customers get
our customers to read their application
with low latency so networking domain
helps with some of the following use
cases it controls and manages the
connectivity of the AWS services within
our account and we can also pick an IP
address range if you're a network
engineer or if you are somebody who
works in networks or are planning to
work a network you will soon realize the
importance of choosing your own IP
address for easy remembering so having
an option to have your own IP address in
the cloud owned Range of IP address in
the cloud it really helps really really
helps in Cloud networking the other
question that get asked would be the
difference between the availability Zone
and the region actually the question
generally gets asked so to test how well
you can actually differentiate and also
correlate the availability Zone and the
region relationship right so a region is
a separate geographic area like the
us2s-1 I mean which represents North
California or the AP South which
represents Mumbai so regions are a
separate geographic area on the contrary
availability Zone resides inside the
region you shouldn't stop there you
should go further and explain about
availability zones and availability
zones are isolated from each other and
some of the services will replicate
themselves within the availability zone
so availability Zone does replication
within them but regions they don't
generally do replication between them
the the other question you could be
asked is what is auto scaling what do we
achieved by Auto scaling so in short
Auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances Whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so Auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular R now this helps business in
not worrying about putting more effort
in managing or continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because Auto
scaling is going to handle it for us so
business does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially an AWS service the
ability to increase and Shrink based on
the need of that art that's how powerful
is auto scaling the other question you
could get asked is what's geo-targeting
in Cloud front now we know that
cloudfront is caching and it caches
content globally in the Amazon caching
service Global wide the whole point is
to provide users worldwide access to the
data from a very nearest server possible
that's the whole point in using or going
for cloudfront then what do you mean by
Geo targeting geotargeting is showing
customer and specific content based on
language we can customize the content
based on what's popular in that place we
can actually customize the content the
URL is the same but we could actually
change the content a little bit not the
whole content otherwise it would be
dynamic but we can change the content a
little bit specific a file or a picture
or a particular Link in a website and
show custom mice content to users who
will be in different parts of the globe
so how does it happen cloudfront will
detect the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or
specific country code it will change the
content and it will send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a Content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or a backing
up an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
Provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports Json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an X3 bucket S3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the S3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say serves A
and B service B is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource B so what happens if
we inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource B first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly if something is
not healthy it would roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first Provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
Provisions those service first and then
Provisions the services that has
dependencies and if you are being hired
for a devops or you know if the
interviewer wanted to test your skill on
systems aside this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody's moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that I can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is gonna cause a downtime right
so that's you should be answering or you
shouldn't be thinking in those terms
because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so updating system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallely with the bigger
ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you are going to use an Ami of the
old machine well and good you don't have
to go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the Ami once you have launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yeah test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and behind
a Route 53 let's say all that you could
do is go to Route 53 update the
information with the new IP address new
IP address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cutover is handled or if
you're using static IP you can actually
remove the static IP from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic Nik card you can actually
remove the new card from the old machine
and attach the new cards to the new
machine so that way we would get near
zero downtime if you are hired for an
architect level you should be worrying
about cost as well along with the
technology and this question would test
how well you manage cost so what are the
tools and techniques we can use in AWS
to identify and correct identify and
know that we are paying the correct
amount for the resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your AWS resources running one way is to
check the billing there's a place where
you can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid Service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost Management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so I'm using a
lot of storage I'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that shouldn't be
storing and then clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost Explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this so that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget all
right this is how much I am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget Mark and anytime it exceeds
anytime it's nearing you would get an
alarm saying that well we're about to
reach the allocated budget amount stuff
like that that way you can go back and
know and you know that how much the bill
is going to be for that month or you can
take steps to control bill amount for
that particular month so AWS budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tags the dev team has spent
so much the production team has spent so
much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that now you'll be able to you know
think in those levels only if you have
cost allocation tags now cost allocation
tags are nothing but the tags that you
would put when you create a resource so
for Production Services you would put as
a production you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing AWS resource other than
the console console is GUI right so in
other words other than GUI how would you
use the AWS resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
Technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the AWS resource are of course
fully you can configure Puri to access
the AWS resources like log into an ec2
instance an ec2 instance does not always
have to be logged in through the console
you could use putty to log into an ec2
instance and like the jump box like the
proxy machine and like the Gateway
machine and from there you can actually
access the rest of the resources so this
is an alternative to the console and of
course we have the AWS CLI in any of the
Linux machines or Windows machines we
can install so that's 0.23 and 4. we can
install AWS CLI for Linux Windows also
for Mac so we can install them and from
there from your local machine we can
access run AWS commands and access
provision monitor the AWS resources the
other ones are we can access the AWS
resource programmatically using AWS SDK
and Eclipse so these are a bunch of
options we have to use the AWS resource
other than the console if you are
interviewed in a company or buy a
company that focuses more on security
and want to use AWS native services for
their security then you will come across
this question what services can be used
to create create a centralized logging
solution the basic Services we could use
are cloudwatch logs store them in S3 and
then use elasticsearch to visualize them
and use Kinesis to move the data from S3
to elasticsearch right so log management
it actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs instead of
logging into an instance or instead of
logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically I can
come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
Cloud watch pushes it to S3 Kinesis
pushes the data from S3 to elasticsearch
and I can do a time-based filter and I
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one hour or whatever the time
window that I wanted to look at so it
helps in getting a good understanding of
the infrastructure as a whole all the
logs are getting saved in one place so
all the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective so we know the services that
can be used and here are some of the
services and how they actually connect
to each other it could be logs that
belongs to One account it could be logs
that belongs to multiple accounts it
doesn't matter you know those three
services are going to work fairly good
and they're gonna inject or they're
gonna like suck logs from the other
accounts put it in one place and help us
to monitor so as you see you have Cloud
watch here that actually tracks the
metrics you can also use cloud trail if
you want to log API calls as well push
them in an S3 bucket so there are
different types of blogs flow logs are
getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same VPC from a different VPC
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client so step one is to deploy the ECS
cluster step two is to restrict access
to the ECS cluster because it's valid
data you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so resting
access to the ECS dashboard and we could
use Lambda also to push the data from
cloud watch to The elasticsearch Domain
and then hibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize the logs instead of looking at
log as just statements or a bunch of
characters a bunch of files kibana helps
us to analyze the logs in a graphical or
a chart or a bar diagram format again in
an interview the interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on AWS security products especially on
the login monitoring even management or
Incident Management then you could have
a question like this what are the native
AWS security logging capabilities now
most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like S3 S3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging DS has
its own logging VPC has its own logging
in additional there are account level
logins like cloudtrail and AWS config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the AWS like Cloud
soil config cloudfront redshift logging
RDS logging VPC flow logs S3 object
logging S3 access login stuff like that
so we're going to look at two servers in
specified cloudtrail now this cloud
trail the very first product in that
picture we just stopped the cloudtrail
provides an very high level history of
the API calls for all the account and
with that we can actually perform a very
good security analysis a security
analysis of our account and these logs
are actually delivered to you can
configure it they can be delivered to S3
for long time archivals and based on a
particular event it can also send an
email notification to us saying hey just
got this error thought I'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service now config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using AWS config all
right the other question you could get
asked is if you know your role includes
taking care of cloud security as well
then the other question you could get
asked is the native services that Amazon
provides or to mitigate DDOS which is
denial of service now not all companies
would go with Amazon native services but
there are some companies which want to
stick with Amazon native Services just
to save them from the headache of
managing the other softwares or bringing
in another tool a third-party tool into
managing DDOS they simply want to stick
with Amazon proprietary Amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using Amazon service to prevent DDOS
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legimate users access the
servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of what denial of services now
look at it these users instead of making
one connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
Mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
would keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to provide event the denial of
service attacks in AWS is cloud shield
and web access firewall AWS web now they
are the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using AWS
Shield or AWS Waf and there are a couple
of other tools that also does when I say
that also does denial of service is not
their primary job but you could use them
for denial of service route 53's purpose
is to provide DNS cloudfront is to
provide caching elastic load balancer
elb's work is to provide load balancing
VPC is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in AWS
shield and AWS web so AWS shield and Waf
are the primary ones but the rest can
also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is this actually will test your
familiarity with the region and the
services available in the region so when
you're trying to provision a service in
a particular region you're not seeing
the service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime Amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
America North Virginia has is more
services compared to Ohio or Compared to
North California So within not America
itself North Virginia is the preferred
one so similarly there are preferred
regions within Europe Middle East and
Africa and prefer regions within Asia
Pacific so anytime we don't see a
service in a particular region chances
that the service is not available in
that region yet we got to check the
documentation and find the nearest
region that offers that service and
start using the service from that region
now you might think well if I'm looking
for a service in Asia let's say in
Mumbai and if it is not available why
not simply switch to North Virginia and
start using it you could but you know
that's going to add more latency to your
application so that's why we need to
check for application which is check for
region which is very near to the place
where you want to serve your customers
and find nearest region instead of
always going back to North Virginia and
deploying an application in North
Virginia again let's is a place there's
a link in aws.com that you can go and
look for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest other region that
provides that service and start using
service from there with the coming up of
cloud a lot of companies have turned
down their monitoring team instead they
want to go with the monitorings that
cloud provides you know nobody wants to
or at least many people don't want to go
through the hassle of at least new
startups and new companies that are
thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage AWS
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a Monitor to
Monitor the website metrics in real time
in AWS the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
Network at a particular point of time so
cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are more services added there is a
reduction in the number of servers
because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloudwatch any cloudwatch can
now support schedule events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action all
right schedule a Trigger Time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with Cloud watch So This Cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with Lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment This Cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with SNS
simple notification service or this
Cloud watch can monitor and based on
what's Happening it can trigger an event
in Lambda and that would in turn run a
function till the environment comes back
to normal so cloudwatch integrates well
with a lot of other AWS Services all
right so cloudwatch has three statuses
green when everything is going good Lo
when the service is degraded and red
when the service is not available green
is good so we don't have to do anything
about it but anytime there's an Lo the
picture that we're looking at it's
actually calling an Lambda function to
debug the application and to fix it and
anytime there's a red alert it
immediately notifies the owner of the
application about well this service is
down and here is the report that I have
here is the metrics that I've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role requires you to manage the
servers as well there are certain job
roles which are on the system side there
are certain job roles which is
development plus system side now you're
responsible for the application and the
server as well so if that's the case you
might be tested with some basic
questions like the different types of
virtualization in AWS and what are the
difference between them all right the
three major types of virtualization are
hvm which is Hardware virtual machine
the other one is PV para virtualization
and the third one is PV on hvm para
virtualization on Hardware virtual
module all right the difference between
them are actually describing them is
actually the difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
Hardware you know the whole Hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these VMS
are booted by executing Master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the PV Amis and when we talk
about PV on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and PV and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words PV on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now you've
been thought that all services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability Zone EBS
is within an availability Zone S3 is
region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that VPC is both
availability and region specific meaning
you know subnets are availability Zone
specific and vpc's region specific stuff
like that so you might have thought you
might have learned in that combination
but that could be some tricky questions
that tests you how well you have
understood the region non-region and
availability non-availability Services I
should say there are services that are
not region specific that would be IAM so
we can't have IM for every availability
Zone and for every region which means
you know users will have to use one
username and password for one region and
anytime they switch to another region
they will have to use another username
and password that that's more work and
that's not a good design as well
authentication has to be Global so IM is
a global Service and which means it's
not region specific on the other hand
Route 53 is again a regional Pacific so
we can't have Route 53 for every region
Route 53 is not a region specific
service it's a global Service and it's
one application users access from
everywhere or from every part of the
world so we can't have one URL or one
DNS name for each region if your
application is a global application and
then web application firewall works well
with cloudfront then cloudfront is a
region based service so the web
application firewall it's not region
specific service it's a global Service
and cloudfront is again a global Service
though you can you know cache content on
a continent and country basis it's still
considered a global Service all right
it's not bound to any region so when you
activate cloudfront you're activating it
away from region or availability zone so
when you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a region
specific service you're activating it
away from availability Zone and regions
so a quick recap I am users groups roles
and accounts they are Global Services
they can be used globally around 53
services are offered at Edge locations
and they are Global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are Global Services
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery Network CDN and they
are offered at Edge locations which are
a global Service in other words
non-region specific service or Beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using Nat or if they are already
securing their environment using Nat by
any of these two methods like Nat
Gateway or Nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a Nat Gateway and that instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different Services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them all
right on a high level they both achieve
providing nothing for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about the availability of it not Gateway
is a managed service by Amazon whereas
not instance is managed by us now I'm
talking about the third Point
maintenance here Nat Gateway is managed
by Amazon that instance is managed by us
and availability of nat Gateway is very
high and availability of nat instance is
less compared to the NAT Gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not Gateway if something
happens to that service Amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth we can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
nag Gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launch and
if we are launching a T2 micro it badly
gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the NAT Gateway is very
high but the performance of the NAT
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the NAT instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
Nat Gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the NAT Gateway but billing
for Nat instance is number of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration and
the type of instance that we use
Security in that Gateway cannot be
assigned meaning it already comes with
full backed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
I can go and change the security because
such a server managed by me or managed
by us I can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the NAT
Gateway is uniform but the size and the
load of the NAT instance changes as per
around Gateway is a Fix-It product but
in that instance can be small instance
can be a big instance so the size and
the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stop state but when you
actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop State the
EBS volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and will never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even an
Cloud consultant level position or even
in an engineering position this is a
very common question that get asked what
are the different types of ec2 instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on-demand instances Port instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of Hardwares for us but if you are
looking at Cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we're going to
be very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
I'll go with on-demand instance because
I pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know I can use them anytime I want
and anytime I don't want I can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances alright so on-demand is cheap
to start with if you are only planning
to use it for a short while but if
you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per hour this is very short
term and irregular workloads and for
testing for development on-demand
instance is a very good use case we
should be using on demand for production
spot instance spot instance allows users
to purchase ec2 at a reduced price and
anytime we have more instances we can
always go and sell it in spot instances
I'm referring to anytime we have more
reserved instances we can always sell
them in spot instance catalog and the
way we buy Spot instance is we actually
put a budget this is how much I'm
willing to pay all right would you be
able to give service within this cost so
anytime the price comes down and meets
the cost that we have put in will be
assigned an instance and anytime the
price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us but in case of
on-demand instances we have bought that
instance for that particular R and it
stays with us but with spot instances it
varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price it goes away to
somebody else and the spot instance
availability is actually based on supply
and demand in the market there's no
guarantee that you will get support
instance at all 9 all right so that's a
caveat there you should be familiar with
that's a caveat there you should be
aware when you are proposing somebody
that we can go for spot instance and
save money it's not always going to be
available if you want your spot instance
to be available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this month so how can I code or
how much can I code stuff like that so
you got to look at those history before
you propose somebody that well we're
gonna save money using spot instance on
the other hand reserved instance provide
cost savings for the company or we can
opt for reserved instances for you know
one year or three years there are
actually three types of reserved
instances light medium and heavy
reserved instances they are based on the
amount that we would be paying and cost
benefit also depends with reserved
instance the cost benefit also depends
based on are we doing all upfront or no
upfront or partial payment then split
the rest as monthly payments so there
are many purchase options available but
overall if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years you should not be going for
on-demand instance you should be going
for reserved instance and that's what
gives you the cost benefit
and in an AWS interview sometimes you
might be asked you know how you interact
with the AWS environment are you using
CLI are you using console and depending
on your answer whether console or a CLI
the panelists put a score okay this
person is CLI specific this person is
console specific or this person has used
AWS environment through the SDK stuff
like that so this question tests whether
you are a CLI person or a console person
and the question goes like this how do
you set up SSH agent forwarding so that
you do not have to copy the key every
time you log in if you have used Puri
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have to put the IP and
the port number along with that you will
have to map or we will have to map the
key in the Puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments right but
in production environment using the same
key or mapping the same key again and
again every time it's actually an hassle
it's considered as a blocker so you
might want to Cache it you might want to
permanently add it in your Puri session
so you can immediately log in and start
using it so here in the place where you
would actually map the private key
there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your SSH to
your pretty instance so we can enable
SSH agent forwarding and that will
actually bind our key to the SSH and
next time when we try to log in we don't
have to always go through mapping the
key and trying to log in all right this
question what are Solaris and ax
operating systems are they available
with AWS that question generally gets
asked to test how familiar are you with
the Amis available how familiar are you
with ec2 how familiar are you with the
ec2 Hardwares available that basically
tests that now the first question or the
first thought that comes to your mind is
well everything is available with AWS
I've seen Windows I've seen Ubuntu I've
seen Red Hat I've seen Amazon Amis and
if I don't see my operating system there
I can always go to Marketplace and try
them if I don't find a Marketplace I can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of Amis available there are a lot of
operating systems available I will be
able to find Solaris and ax but that's
not the case Solaris and ax are not
available with AWS that's because
Solaris uses a different I mean Solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public Cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power CPU and not on Intel and as of now
Amazon does not provide Power machines
this should not be confused with HPC
which is a high performance Computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different Hardwares different
CPU itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate the their
infrastructure using Amazon native
Services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or Auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing bugs in an OS
stuff like that you know once an ec2
instance crashes like it goes on a over
spanic or there are various reasons why
it would fail so we don't have to really
worry about fixing it we can always
relaunch that instance and that would
fix it but what if it happens at two
o'clock in the night what if it happens
that during a weekend when nobody is in
office now looking or monitoring those
instances so you would want to automate
that not only on a weekend or during
midnights but it's general practice good
to automate it so you could face this
question how do you actually automate an
ec2 instance once it fails and the
answer to that question is using Cloud
watch we can recover the instance so as
you see there is an alarm threshold a
set in Cloud watch and once the
threshold is met meaning if there is an
error if there is a failure if the ec2
instance is not responding for a certain
while we can set an alarm and once the
alarm is met let's say the CPU
utilization stayed high for 5 minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like I'm gonna
do it so the other option to stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody is using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets I mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody is using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the CPU
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you all
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloudwatch action to terminate the
instance when the CPU is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or CPU is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of Ami designs there are
a lot of Ami designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back Amis and the other one is just
enough OS Ami je OS Ami and the other
one is hybrid type Amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed Ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's ready to use Ami and
this is the simplest Ami to deploy can
be a bit expensive it can be a bit a
cumbersome because you'll have to do a
lot of work beforehand you could use the
Amis a lot of planning a lot of thought
process will go into it and the Ami is
ready to use right you hand over the Ami
to somebody and it's ready to use or if
you want to reuse the Ami it's already
ready for you to use so that's full
baked Ami the other one is just enough
operating system Ami just like the name
says it has I mean as you can also see
in the diagram or in the picture it
covers a part of the OS all bootstraps
are already packed properly and the
security monitoring logging and the
other stuff are configured at the time
of deployment or at the time you would
be using it so not much thought process
will go in here the only focus is on
choosing the operating system and what
goes the operating system specific
agents or bootstraps that goes into the
operating system that's all we worry
about the advantage of this is it's
flexible meaning you can choose to
install additional softwares at the time
of deploying but that's going to require
an additional expertise on the person
who will be using the Ami so that's
another overhead there but the advantage
is that it's kind of flexible I can
change the configurations during the
time of deployment the other one is the
hybrid Ami now the hybrid Ami actually
falls in between the fully baked Ami and
just enough operating system options so
these Amis have some features of the big
type and some features of the just
enough OS type so as you see the
security monitoring logging are packed
in that Ami and the runtime environments
are installed stalled during the time of
a deployment so this is where the strict
company policies would go into the Ami
company policies like you got to lock
this you got to monitor this these are
the ports that generally gets open in
all the systems stuff like that so they
strictly go into the Ami and sits in an
AMF format and during deployment you
have the flexibility of choosing the
different runtime and the application
that sits in an ec2 instance another
very famous question you would face in
an interview is how can you recover
login to an ec2 instance to which you
lost the key well we know that if the
key is lost we can't recover it there
are some organizations that integrate
their ec2 instances with an ad that's
different all right so you can go and
reset the password in the ad and you
will be able to log in with the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise a ticket with Amazon
not possible they're not going to help
it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the ec2
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run in that easy to do
instance and then it detach the root
volume for that instance of course it's
going to require a stop and start to
detach the root volume from the instance
attach the root volume to another
instance as a temporary volume or it
could be a temporary instance that
you've launched only to fix this issue
and then login to that instance and to
that particular volume and modify the
configuration file configuration file
modify it to use the new key and then
move the root volume back to its
original position and restart the
instance and now the instance is going
to have the new key and you also have
the new key with which you can log in so
that's how we go ahead and fix it now
let's move on to some product specific
or S3 product specific questions a
general perception is S3 and EBS can be
used interchangeably and the interviewer
would want to test your knowledge on S3
and EVS well if EBS uses S3 that's true
but they can't be interchangeably used
so you might face this question what are
some key differences between AWS S3 and
EBS well the differences are S3 is an
object store meaning you can't install
anything in it you can store drive files
but you can't actually install in it
it's not a file system but ABS is a file
system you can install Services I mean
install applications in it and that's
going to run stuff like that and talking
about performance S3 is much faster and
abs is super faster when accessing from
the instance because from the instance
if you need to access S3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the S3 or S3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your VPC to access S3 S3 does
not come under a VPC but EBS comes under
a VPC it's on the same vbc so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to S3 EBS is very local so that
way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
S3 and abs S3 is replicated the data in
S3 is replicated across the data centers
but EBS is replicated within the data
center meaning S3 is replicated across
availability zones EBS is within an
availability zone so that way redundancy
is a bit less in EVS in other words
blurrency is higher in S3 than EBS and
talking about security of S3 is3 can be
made private as well as public meaning
anybody can access S3 from anywhere in
the internet that's possible with S3 but
EBS can only only be accessed when
attached to an ec2 instance right just
one instance can access it whereas S3 is
publicly directly accessible the other
question related to S3 security is how
do you allow access to a user to a
certain a user to a certain bucket which
means this user is not having access to
S3 at all but this user needs to be
given access to a certain bucket how do
we do it the same case applies to
servers as well in few cases there could
be an instance where a person is new to
the team and you actually don't want
them to access the production service
now he is in the production group and by
default he or she is granted access to
that server but you specifically want to
deny access to that production server
till the time he or she is matured
enough to access or understand the
process understand the do's and don'ts
before they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we were actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put a tag on them put attack saying well
they are highly critical they are medium
critical and they are not critical at
all still they're in production stuff
like that and then you would pick the
users who wants to or who should be or
should not be given access to a certain
server and you would actually allow the
user to access or not access servers
based on a specific tag in other words
you can use actually tags in in the
previous step we put tags on the
critical server right so you would
Define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources for this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are TAG
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them the same goes for
bucket as well or if an organization is
excessively using S3 for their data
storage because of the benefit that it
provides the cost and the durability you
might get asked this question which is
organizations would replicate the data
from one region to another region for
additional data durability and for
having data redundancy not only for that
they would also do that for Dr purposes
for Disaster Recovery if the whole
region is down you still have the data
available somewhere else and you can
pick and use it some organizations would
store data in different regions for
compliance reasons to provide low
latency access to their users who are
local to that region stuff like that so
when companies do replication how do you
make sure that there is consistency in
the replication how do you make sure
that a replication is not failing and
the data gets transferred for sure and
there are logs for that replication this
is something that the companies would
use where they are excessively using S3
and they are fully relying on the
replication in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have Region 2 and region 1
is the source bucket and region two is
the destination bucket all right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or or made a copy in the region
two bucket and the problem is sometimes
it fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these Services together and
create an cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloudwatch that
make sure that the data is moved no data
is failing again there's Cloud watch on
the other end make sure that the data is
moving and then we have the logs
generated through cloudtrail and that's
actually written in dynamodb and if
there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an SMS
or you get notified through an email
using the SNS service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication some common issues that
company companies face in VPC is that we
all know that I can use Route 53 to
resolve an IP address externally from
the internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom DNS name that does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a VPC is not resolving the server
through the DNS you can access it
through the IP but not through the DNS
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default VPC does not
allow that's the default feature and we
will have to enable the DNS hostname
resolution before now this is for the
custom DNS not for the default DNS that
comes along this is for the custom DNS
so we will have to enable the DNS
hostname resolution so our will have to
enable DNS hostname resolution so they
actually resolve let's say I want to
connect to a server one dot
simplylearn.com by default it's not
allowed but if I enable this option then
I will be able to connect to server one
simplylearn.com if a company has vpcs in
different regions and they have head
office in a central place and the rest
of them are Branch offices and they are
connecting to the head office for Access
or you know for saving data or for
accessing certain files or certain data
or storing data all right so they would
actually mimic The Hub and spoke
topology where you have the VPC which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then you
would have a local vpcs or Branch
offices in different other regions and
they get connected to the VPC in the
central location and the question is how
do you actually connect the multiple
sites to a VPC and make communication
happen between them by default it does
not do that we know that vpcs they need
to be paired between them in order to
access the resources let's look at this
picture right so I have like a customer
Network or Branch offices in different
parts and they get connected to a VPC
that's fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices the remote
offices they are connecting to the VPC
and they're talking but they can't
connect or they can't talk to each other
that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic needs to or
they should be able to talk to each
other but they should not have direct
connection between them which means that
they will have to come and hit the VPC
and then reach the other customer
Network which is in Los Angeles or which
is in New York right that's the
requirement so that's possible with some
architecting in the cloud so that's
using VPN Cloud Hub you look at this
dotted lines which actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the VPC Again by default it
doesn't happen Cloud Hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the VPC or headquarters data center
which is in the VPC you have control or
the VPC has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to I mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the VPC the other question
person you could get asked is name and
explain some security products and
features available in VPC well VPC
itself is a security service it provides
security service to the application but
how do you actually secure the VPC
itself that's the question and yes there
are products that can actually secure
the VPC or the VPC delivers those
products to secure the application
access to the vpcs restricted through a
network access control list all right so
that's a security product in VPC and a
VPC has security groups that protects
the instances from unwanted inbound and
outbound traffic and network access
control list protects the subnets from
unwanted inbound and outbound access and
there are flow logs we can capture in
VPC that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a VPC which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern stuff like that so
there are some security products and
features available in VPC now how do you
monitor VPC VPC is a very important
concept very important Service as well
everything sits in a VPC most of the
service sits in a VPC except for Lambda
and S3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a VPC for
security reasons so how do you monitor
your VPC how do you gain some visibility
on your VPC well we can gain visibility
on our VPC using VPC flow log that's the
basic Service as you see it actually
captures what's allowed what's not
allowed stuff like that which IPS
allowed which IP is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and Cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed I mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who is not allowed
that kind of detail and Cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a sudden hike
in the graph there's a sudden hike and
something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at cloudwatch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation and the key to clear them is
to understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
come rule number one and then the second
rule is try to compare and contrast the
services mentioned or try to compare and
contrast the answers you can easily read
out one or two answers and then you will
be left with only two answers to decide
from you know so that also helps you
with time and that's how that also helps
you with some Precision in your answer
so number one read between the lines
number two compare and contrast the
services and you'll be able to easily
read out the wrong ones so let's try
answering this question suppose you are
a game designer and you want to develop
a game with a single digit millisecond
latency which of the following database
Services would you choose so we know
that the following are database services
are good enough all right and it talks
about millisecond latency that's the key
point and the third thing is it's a game
it could be a mobile game it's a game
that you are trying to design and you
need the millisecond latency and it has
to be a database all right so let's talk
about the options available RDS RDS is a
database for sure is it good for game
design we'll come back to that Neptune
Neptune is a graph a database service in
Amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation and snowball is actually a
storage all right it's it's a transport
medium I would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
RDS and dynamodb so if we need to talk
about RDS RDS is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an SQL
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for Banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for or anything that has to
do with the gaming so the only option
left is dynamodb again it's the right
answer dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key Value Store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of AWS services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so it talks about real-time
monitoring a firewall manager what does
it provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and AWS guard duty is and
thread detection service it does
monitoring it it does continuously
monitor our environment but it monitors
for threats all right only threats now
let's talk about Cloud watch a cloud
watch is a service that helps to track
metrics it's a service that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
I mean we have one more option left
that's EBS so what's EBS EBS is a block
storage elastic Block store if we
abbreviate EBS it's elastic Block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threads of course
it does monitoring so there's I mean if
there is one relation between Cloud
watch and guard Duty that's monitoring
so easily we can actually find ourselves
slipped towards picking our duty but
know that God do you is only for gaining
security inside but not about gaining
AWS service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to get a system
wide or an AWS wide or an account wide
and it has number of metrics we can
monitor and get a very good Insight of
how a service is performing be it CPU be
it Ram beat Network utilization beat the
connection failures Cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily alright so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here Shield AWS Massey
AWS inspector Amazon Cognito so let's
try to weed out Services which are not
relevant to it so what's AWS Shield AWS
Shield is actually a service that
provides a DDOS mitigation or DDOS
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option AWS Maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up an mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one AWS inspector now AWS
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's right
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with improving the security and
compliance of the apps that we deploy in
the cloud so kind of looks like it could
be because it has to do with apps the
last one Cognito now Cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator to have control access
over web and mobile apps and it's a
service that helps us to sign up and
assign in to an mobile and web app so
that very much looks like we found the
answer so cognitive service that helps
web app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
is I mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognitive Cognito is a
service that helps us to set up sign up
sign in and have access control over the
users who will be using our mobile and
web app all right how about this
question you are an ml engineer or a
machine learning engineer who is on the
lookout for a solution that will
discover sensitive information that your
Enterprise stores in AWS and then uses
NLP to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following Services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the about
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning your machine
learning engineer who's looking for a
service that will help you to discover
information at your Enterprise store so
we're talking about storage discover
information in store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the AWS IAM if we abbreviate it it's a
identity and access manage months it's
identity and access management nothing
to do with identifying sensitive data
and managing it so the first two is
already out of the equation and then the
AWS is Massey we already had a quick
definition description for AWS Mass E
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning kind of looks
like it could be it it's a security
service that uses machine learning and
it discovers and classifies the
sensitive information not only that it
does not stop there it goes beyond and
protects the sensitive data AWS Mass it
kind of looks like but we still have one
more option to look at which is cloud
HMS Cloud HMS is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of 50 of it it's a security
service it encrypts helps us protect
other data but AWS Maxi is right on spot
it's a machine learning service it helps
us to to classify the data and also to
protect the data so the answer for this
question would be AWS Massey so hope you
kind of get it how this is going so
first we apply the thumb rule identify
the question that's being asked read
between the lines and then try to find
the service that meets your requirement
then finding the service is by verse
reading out the wrong ones a recollect
everything that you've learned about the
service and see how well that matches
with those hints that you have picked up
and if that doesn't match weed that out
then you'll end up with two just two to
decide from at some point and then it
becomes easy for you to decide click on
the question submit it and then move on
to the other question in your interview
all right so how about this one you are
a system administrator in your company
which is running most of its
infrastructure on AWS you are required
to track your users and keep a look on
how your users are being authenticated
all right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage AWS users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the AWS
resources right you are to give them
permission number one and then I mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it IAM
is a service that helps us to looking at
the permissions we can actually predict
whether the user or the group will have
servers or not so that helps us to get a
track of who's able to use who's not
able to use certain servers and all that
stuff so it kind of looks like but we
have other three options left let's look
at AWS firewall manager just like the
name says it's actually a firewall
manager it helps us to manage multiple
firewalls simple as that and shield is a
service it's a service that's used to
protect denial of service or distributed
denial of service an API Gateway is a
service that makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor and secure API so I mean
it's completely on the API side very
Less on user and how you authenticate
your user we can get that by looking at
the name itself right if you abbreviate
it or if you if you try to find a
definition for the name API Gateway you
would get it it has to do with API but
if you upgrade AWS IAM its identity and
access management pretty much meets the
requirement but for the problem
statement about it's AWS identity and
access management that's the right
answer all right let's look at this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public IP address in order to make
them communicate with the internet and
other instances you will use this
service which of the following is this
service so it talks about using public
and private IP address so this service
uses IP address and then this service
helps us to allow of and deny
connections to the internet and to the
other instances so you get the question
is it let's pick the service that helps
us achieve it Route 53 Route 53 is
actually a DNS service right so it's not
a service that's used to allow or deny
no it does not do that VPC VPC uses
public and private IP address yes so
kind of looks like a VPC helps us to
allow I mean the security in VPC the
security group the network access
control list in a VPC the routing table
in a VPC that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular IP
address or to a particular service
within the VPC or outside of the VPC so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the Amazon VPC Gateway API Gateway
we know that it's a managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish maintain and monitor apis and
secure apis that has completely do with
API not with IP Cloud front we know
about cloudfront that it's a Content
delivery Network and it provides global
distribution of servers where our
content can be cached it could be video
or or bulk Media or anything else they
can be cached locally so users can
easily access them and download them
easily alright so that's cloudfront now
at this point after looking at all four
it looks like VPC is the right answer
and in fact VPC is the right answer VPC
has public IP address VPC he can help us
with the private IP address VPC can be
used to allow deny connection based on
the security group Access Control list
and routing table it has so that's right
answer is VPC all right how about this
one this platform as a service or
platform as a DB service provides us
with the cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time-consuming
administrative tasks so this question is
very clear it's a DB service we got to
look for and it's a service that can
provide automating some of the time
consuming tasks it has to be resizable
at the same time so let's talk about
Amazon rational database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if that
matches the definition that we've
figured out about elastic cache it's
actually a caching service it's again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving high throughput and low
latency in memory data store so it's not
a full-blown database and it does not
come with any Amazon provisioned
Automation in it for automating any of
the administration tasks now it does not
come up with anything like that yeah we
can resize the capacity as and when
needed but automation it's not there yet
and moreover it's not a database so
that's out of the equation VPC is not a
recessable one you know once we have
designed VPC it's fixed it can be
resized so that's out of the equation
and uh Amazon Glacier Glacier is a
storage but not a database all right so
that's again of the equation so the tie
is kind of between Amazon rational
database service and Amazon elastic
cache because they both Aid the database
service but elastic cache is not a
full-blown database it actually helps
the database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's Amazon relational
database so that's the one which is a
platform as a service it's the one which
can be resized it's the one which can be
used to automate the time consuming
administrative tasks all right let's
talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or Consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like assigning task or hiring AWS
exports for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed Amazon elastic
map reduce map reduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has nothing to do with
accessing human researchers all right
let's talk about mechanical terms it's a
web service that provides a human
Workforce that's the definition for it
for example automation is good but not
everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be a repeated task a one-time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for Automation and anything
that requires intelligence or anything
that's a special case all right
automation can do reperative tasks
automation can do precise work but it
has to be repeated tasks scenario you
know it should have been there already
only then that can be executed but if
it's a new scenario and it requires
appropriate addressing then it requires
human thoughts so we could hire
researchers and Consultants who can help
solve a problem using Amazon Mechanical
Turk the other two are already out of
the equation now Dev pay is actually a
payment system through Amazon and
multi-factor authentication as it says
it's an authentication system so the
right answer is Amazon Mechanical Turk
all right this sounds interesting let's
look at this one this service is used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on AWS which of the following
is this AWS service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
so it also should have the ability to
use kubernetes which is a container
orchestration service all right the
first one an Amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one AWS
batch it's a service that enables it
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing I mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic Beanstalk that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances not with
containerized instances so that's again
out of the equation would light still be
a good tie for elastic container service
what's slide sale now light sale is a
service it's called as virtual private
server without a VPC it's called as a
virtual private server it comes with a
predefined in the compute storage
networking capacity it's actually a
server not a container right so at this
point that also becomes out of the
equation so it's Amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code Amazon ec2
Auto scaling easy to order scaling ec2
is elastic compute Cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation AWS
Lambda now Lambda is a service It's
actually an event driven serverless
Computing platform and Lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and setup events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about Lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because Lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
servers by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two service to
talk about AWS batch all right batch is
service that enables ID professionals to
run batch job we know that and about the
inspector Amazon inspector it's actually
a service that helps us to increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance well
that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement and the
question was run code without
provisioning a server and without any
more space for confusion AWS Lambda is a
service or is the service that runs code
without provisioning and managing
Services right the right one would be
AWS Lambda all right let's get started
so in an environment where there is a
lot of automation infrastructure
automation you'll be posted with this
question how can you add an existing
instance to a new auto scaling group now
this is when you are taking an instance
away from the auto scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to re-add that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's going to
take part in it right only then the auto
scaling is going to count it as part of
it it's not a straight procedure you
know when you remove them you know it
doesn't get automatically re-added I've
had worked with some clients when their
developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and what whatever
they fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like I said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance uh to the auto
Skilling group there are a few steps
that we need to follow so the first one
would be to under the ec2 instance
console right under the instance under
actions in specific you know there's an
option called attach to Auto scaling
group right if you have multiple Auto
scaling groups in your account or in the
region that you're working in then
you're going to be posted with the
different Auto scaling groups that you
have in your account let's say you have
five Auto scaling groups or five
different application you know you're
going to be posted with five different
or scaling groups and then you would
select the auto scaling the appropriate
Auto scaling group and attach the
instance to that particular or a scaling
group while adding to the order scaling
group if you want to change the instance
type and that's possible as well
sometimes when you want to add the
instance back to the auto scaling group
there would be requirement that you
change the instance type to a better one
to a better family to the better
instance type you could do that at that
time and after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step up process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they're dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating and VM into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to Amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth moving the
instance to the cloud given the
additional bills and visuals features
available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes you know cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and Supply transparency is
this application in high demand you know
is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are few things that needs
to be considered before we move the
application to the cloud and then if the
application does the application needs
to be provisioned immediately is there
an urge is there an urge to provision
the application immediately that's
something that needs to be considered if
the application requires to go online if
the application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on-premises
procuring buying an infrastructure
buying the band that buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their software so buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so if
the application cannot wait you know
waiting means uh you know Workforce
productivity loss is it so we would want
to immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is the urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if the the software or if
the product that you're launching it
requires Hardware it requires an updated
or Hardware all the time that's not
going to be possible in on-premises we
try to deal with Legacy infrastructure
all the time in on-premises but in the
cloud they're constantly upgrading their
hard ways only then they can keep
themselves up going in the market so
they constantly the Cloud providers are
constantly updating their hard ways and
if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the Hardwares
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible the software version the
licensing is as latest as possible then
that's a candidate to be moved to the
cloud and if the application does not
want to go through any risk if the
application is very sensitive to
failures if the application is very much
stacked to the revenue of the company
and you don't want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business agility you know
moving to the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's Amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails Amazon make sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make yourself aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between Amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is RTO and RPO in AWS they are
essentially Disaster Recovery terms when
you're planning for Disaster Recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about RTO and
RPO now what's the RTO what's the RPO in
your environment or how do you define
RTO how do you define RPO or some
general questions that get asked RTO is
recovery time objective RTO stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to have happen
or for the recovery to finish when and
disaster strikes so RTO is in the future
right how much time is it going to take
to fix and bring everything to normal so
that's rtu on the other hand RPO is
recovery Point objective which is the
maximum amount of data laws your company
is willing to accept as measured in time
RPO always refers to the backups the
number of backups the the frequency of
the backups right because when an outage
happens you can always go back to the
latest backup right and if the latest
backup was before 12 hours you have lost
the in between 12 hours of data data
storage right so RPO is the acceptable
amount if the company wants less RPO RPO
is 1R then you should be planning on
taking backups everyone up if RPO is 12
hours then you should be planning on
taking backups every 12 hours so that's
how RPO and RTO you know helps Disaster
Recovery the fourth question you could
get asked is if you would like to
transfer huge amount of data which is
the best option among a snowball
snowball Edge and snowmobile again this
is a question that get asked if the
company is dealing with a lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with migrating data
into the cloud I'm talking about a huge
amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now AWS snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified AWS region on the other hand
AWS snowball Edge adds additional
Computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball Edge has a compute function
attached to it a snowmobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is AWS cloud formation different from
AWS elastic bean stock you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through CLI and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different Services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and the elastic bean
stock gives us a small contained
environment in which we can run our
application and cloud formation supports
the infrastructure needs of many
different types of application like the
Enterprise application the Legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock It's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bean stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using cloud formation to manage
their infrastructure using or if they're
using infrastructure or any of the
infrastructure as a code Services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an AWS cloud
formation template so it has a four or
five basic elements right and the
template is in the form of Json or in
yaml format right so it has parameters
it has outputs it has data it has
resources and then the format or the
format version or the file format
version for the cloud formation template
so parameter is nothing but it actually
lets you to specify the type of ec2
instance that you want the type of RDS
that you want all right so ec2 is an
umbrella RDS is an umbrella and
parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rdas are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the RDS service so
that's what parameter is in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
Output the name of an S3 bucket that was
created if you want to Output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
Output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted in the
result section so we can simply go and
look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or Cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource RDS is a resource and S3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and the NAT
Gateway is a resource VPC is a reserve
so you see all these components are the
resources and there is so section in the
cloud formation defines what are the AWS
Cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0909 2010 that's the latest version
number you'll be able to find that on
the top of the cloud formation template
and that version number defines the
capabilities of the cloud formation
template so just need to make sure that
it's the latest all the time still
talking about cloud formation this is
another classic question what happens
what when one of the resource in a stack
cannot be created successfully well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful when the cloud formation
cannot you know go forward cloud
formation cannot create additional
resources because we have reached the
elastic IP limits elastic IP limit per
region is 5 right and if you have
already used five IPS and a cloud
formation is trying to buy three more
IPS you know we've hit the soft limit
till we fix that with Amazon cloud
formation will not be able to you know
launch additional we know resources and
additional IPS so it's going to cancel
and roll back everything that's true
with a missing ec2 Ami as well if an Ami
is included in the template and but the
Ami is not actually present then cloud
formation is going to search for the Ami
and because it's not present it's going
to roll back and delete all the
resources that it created so that's what
cloud formation does it simply rolls
back all the resources that it created I
mean if it sees a failure it would
simply roll back all the resources that
it created and this feature actually
simplifies the system administration and
layout Solutions built on top of AWS
cloud formation so at any point we know
that there are no orphan resources in
the in in our environment you know
because something did not work or
because there was an you know cloud
formation executed some there are no
orphan resources in our account at any
point we can be sure that if cloud
formation is launching a resource and
it's going to fail and it's going to
come back and delete all the resources
it's created so there are no orphan
resources in our account now let's talk
about some questions in elastic Block
store again if the environment deals
with a lot of automation you could be
thrown this question how can you
automate easy to backup using EBS it's
actually a six step process to automate
the ec2 backups we'll need to write a
script to automate the below steps using
AWS API and these are the steps that
should be found in the scripts first get
the list of instances and then and then
the script that we are writing should be
able to connect to AWS using the API and
list the Amazon ABS volumes that are
attached locally to the instance and
then it needs to list the snapshots of
each volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be invalid right once you have
some 10 latest snapshots any snapshot
that you have taken before that 10
becomes invalid because you have
captured the latest and 10 snapshot
coverage is enough for you and then the
fifth point is to create a snapshot of
each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot anytime a new snapshot gets
created the oldest snapshot on the list
needs to go away so we need to include
options we need to include scripts in
our script lines in our script that make
sure that it's deleting the older
snapshots which are older than the
retention period that we are mentioning
another question that you could see in
the interview be it written interview
beat online interview or beat and
telephonic or face-to-face interview is
what's the difference between EBS and
instance store let's talk about EBS
first EBS is kind of permanent storage
the data in it can be restored at a
later point when we save data in ABS the
data lives even after the lifetime of
the ec2 instance for example we can stop
the instance and the data is still going
to be present in EBS we can move the EBS
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so ABS is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine abs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of The
Machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with EBS so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is EBS is permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using EBS and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of EFS like EBS
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take EFS to EFS backup solution EFS
does not support snapshot like EBS EFS
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for EFS elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one EFS to another EFS and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
EFS and this can be automated right any
data that we store in EFS can be
automatically replicated to another EFS
and once this EFS goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole EFS is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other EFS
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an One Step
configuration it's a cycle there are
series of steps that's involved before
we can achieve EFS to EFS backup the
first thing is to sign in to the AWS
Management console and under EFS or
click on EFS to EFS restore button from
the services list and from there we can
use the region selector in the console
navigation bar to select the actual
region in which we want to work on and
from there a venture that we have
selected the right template you know
some of the templates would be you know
EFS to EFS backup granular backups
incremental backups right so there are
some templates the kind of backups that
you want to take do you want to take
granular do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on Save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an EFS to EFS backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with a data management there
are easy options to create snapshots but
deleting snapshots is not always and you
know click button or a single step
configuration so you might be facing a
question like how do you Auto delete old
snapshots and the procedure is like this
now as best practice we will take
snapshot shots of EBS volume to S3 all
snapshots get stored in S3 we know that
now and we can use AWS Ops automator to
automatically handle all snapshots the
Ops automator service it allows us to
create copy delete EBS snapshots so
there are cloud formation templates
available for AWS Ops automator and this
automator template will scan the
environment and it would take snapshots
it would you know copy the snapshot from
one region to another region if you want
I know if you're setting up a Dr
environment and not only that based on
the retention period that we create it's
going to delete the snapshots which are
older than the retention period so life
or managing snapshot is made a lot
easier because of this Ops automator
cloud formation template moving into
questions and elastic load balancer this
again could be an a question in the
interview what are the different type
types of load balances in AWS and what's
their use case what's the difference
between them and as of now as we speak
there are three types of load balances
which are available in AWS the first one
being application load balancer just
like the name says the application load
balancer works on the application layer
and deals with HTTP and https request
and it it also supports part based
routing for example simplylearn.com
some web page simplylearn.com another
website so it's going to direct the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the URL so that's path based routing
so it supports that and not only that it
can support a port based a colon 8080
colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know based
on that Port also it can take a routing
decision and that's what application
load balancer does on the other hand we
have Network load balancer and the
network load balance lenser makes
routing decisions at the transport level
it's faster because it has very less
thing to work on it works on Lower OSI
layer it works on a lower layer so it
has very less information to work with
than compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a Target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path based or Port
based routing it does simple routing and
because of it it's faster and then we
have classic load balancer which is kind
of expiring as we speak Amazon is
discouraging people using classic load
balancer but there are companies which
are still using classic load balancer
they are the ones who are the first one
to step into Amazon when classic load
balancer was the first load balancer or
the only load balancer available at that
point so it supports HTTP https TCP SSL
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between a load balance report and the
container Port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then after
some point Amazon said instead of having
one load balancer address all type of
traffic we're gonna have a two load
balances called as the child from the
classic to load balancer and one is
going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balances talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in AWS
elastic or load balancing there are
three types of load balancer we just
spoke about it application load balancer
is used if we need flexible application
management and TLS termination and
network load balancer if we require
Extreme Performance and the load
balancing should happen on based on
static IPS for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from
easy to Classic Network now this is an
older version of VPC or this is what was
present before VPC was created easy to
Classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of this
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall and AWS we cannot
avoid discussion talking about web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use AWS Waf in monitoring your
AWS applications Waf or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and Waf helps
us control which traffic Source your
application should be allowed or a Blog
which traffic from a certain Source now
which source or which traffic from a
certain Source should be allowed or
blocked your application with Waf we can
also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has I mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack So based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and Waf can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then block all requests and count
all requests for a new policy so it's
also an monitoring and Management
Service which actually counts all the
policies or counts all the requests that
matches a particular policy that we
create and some of the characteristics
we can mention in AWS web are the origin
IPS and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
Origin an IP allow block based on
strings that appear in the request we
can allow block or count based on the
origin country length of the request
yeah we can block and count the presence
of malicious scripts in an connection
you know we can count the request
headers or we can allow block a certain
request header and we can count the
presence of a malicious SQL code in a
connection that we get and that want to
reach our application still talking
about security what are the different
AWS IM categories we can control using
AWS IIM we can do the following one is
create and manage IM users and once the
user database gets bigger and bigger we
can create and manage them in groups and
in IM we can use it to manage the
security credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like MFA and you know rotating the
passwords resetting the password there
are few things we could do with the IAM
and finally we can create policies that
actually grants access to AWS services
and resources another question you will
see is what are the policies that you
can set for your users password so some
of the policies that we can set for the
user password is the minimum length or
you know the complexity of the password
by at least having one number or one
special characters in the password so
that's one and then the requirement of a
specific character types including you
know uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password would be and and try
to hack them so we can set the length of
the password we can set the complexity
in the password and then we can set an
automatic expiration of the password so
after a certain time the user is forced
to create a new password so the password
is not still old and easy to guess in
the environment and we can also set
settings like the user should contact
the admin I mean when the password is
about to expire so you know you can get
a hold of how the user is setting their
password is it having good complexity in
it is it meeting company standards or
there are few things that we can control
and set for the users when the users are
setting or recreating the password
another question that could be posted in
an interview so to understand your
understanding of IEM is what's the
difference between an IM role and an IM
user let's talk about IM user let's
touch small and then go big or let's
start simple and then talk about the
complex one the IM user has a permanent
long-term credential and it's used to
interact directly with AWS services and
on the other hand IEM role is an IM
entity that defines a set of permissions
for making a AWS service request so IM
user is an permanent credential and role
are temporary credentials and IM user
has full access to all AWS IEM
functionalities and with role trusted
entities such as IEM users application
or AWS Services assume are the role so
when an IM user is given an permission
you know it sticks within the IM user
but with roles we can give permissions
to Applications we can give permissions
to users in the same account in a
different account a corporate ID we can
give permissions to ec2 S3 RDS VPC and
lot more role is wide and IM user is is
not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that IM user let's
talk about manage policies in AWS manage
policies there are two types you know
customer managed and Amazon managed so
manage policies are IM resources that
Express permissions using the IAM policy
language and we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the IM user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so I can
have like three services four Services
point to a particular policy and if I
edit that particular policy it's going
to reflect on those three or four
services so anything that I allow is
going to be allowed for those four
Services anything that I denied is going
to be denied for the four Services
imagine what would be without the IM
managed policy will have to go and
specifically allow deny on those
different instances four or five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like I said there are
two types of managed policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policies and then the other is managed
by AWS which is AWS managed policy this
question can you give an example of an
IM policy and a policy summary this is
actually to test how well-versed are you
with the AWS console the answer to that
question is look at the following policy
this policy is used to Grant access to
add update and delete objects from a
specific folder now in this case name of
the folder is example folder and it's
present in a bucket called example
bucket so this is an IAM policy on the
other hand the policy summary is a list
of access level resource and conditions
for each service defined in a policy so
IM policy is all about one particular
resource and the policy summary is all
about multiple resources with IM policy
it was only talking about S3 bucket and
one particular S3 bucket here it talks
about cloud formation template Cloud
watch logs ec2 elastic bean stock
services summary summary of resources
and the permissions and policies
attached to them that's what policy
summary is all about another question
could be like this what's the use case
of IAM and how does IM help your
business two important or primary work
of IM is to help us manage IM users and
their access it provides a secure access
to multiple users to their appropriate
AWS resources so that's one it does and
the second thing it does is manage
access for Federated users Federated
users or non-iam users and through IAM
we can actually allow and provide a
secured access to resources in our AWS
account to our employees without the IM
user no they could be authenticated
using the active directory they could be
authenticated using the Facebook
credential Google credential Amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party identity
management all right so we could
actually trust them and we could give
them access to our account based on the
trust relationship that we have built
with the other identity of systems all
right so two things one is manage users
and their access for manage IAM user and
their access in our AWS environment and
second is manage access for Federated
users who are non-im users and more
importantly IM is a free service and
with that will only be charged for the
use of the resources not for the IM
username and password that we create all
right let's now talk about some of the
questions in Route 53 one classic
question that could be asked in an
interview is what is the difference
between latency based routing and Geo
DNS or Geo based DNS routing now the jio
based DNS routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of of the
geographic location of the request and
on the other hand the latency based
routing utilizes latency measurements
between networks and data centers now
latency based routing is used where you
want to give your customers the lowest
latency as possible so that's when we
would use latency based routing and on
the other hand a geo-based routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites based on the country
they are browsing from you know you
could have you know two different or
three different websites for the same
URL you know take Amazon the shopping
website for example when we go to
amazon.com from in the US it directs us
to the US webpage where the products are
different the currency is different
right and the flag and and a couple of
other advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from India it gets directed to the
amazon.com Indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the country
they're trying to browse if you want to
direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a
geo-based routing another use case of
geobase routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the DNS requests sorry if you should
handle all the requests you know from a
country within the country then you
would do geo based routing now you
wouldn't direct the customer to a server
which is in another country all right
you would direct the customer to a
server which is very local to them
that's another use case of jio based
routing and like I said for latency
based routing the whole goal or aim is
to achieve minimum end user latency if
you are hired for the architect role and
if that requires working a lot on the
DNS then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted Zone a domain is
actually a collection of data describing
a self-contained administrative and
Technical unit on the internet all right
so for example you know simplylearn.com
is actually a domain on the other hand
hosted zone is actually an container
that holds information about how you
want to Route traffic on the internet to
a specific domain for example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted Zone
whereas simplylearn.com is an domain so
in other words in hosted Zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it LMS is a prefix here FTP is a prefix
mail.simplieron.com is a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from Route 53
would be how does Amazon Route 53
provide High availability and low
latency the way I am Amazon Route 53
provides High availability and low
latency is by globally distributed DNS
servers Amazon is a global Service and
they have DNA Services globally any
customer doing a query from different
parts of the world they get to reach an
DNS server which is very local to them
and that's how it provides low latency
now this is not true with all the DNS
providers there are DNS providers who
are very local to a country who are very
local to a continent so they don't they
generally don't provide low latency
service right it's always high latency
it's low latency for local users but
anybody browsing from a different
country or a different continent it's
going to be high latency for them but
that's not again true with Amazon Amazon
is a globally distributed DNS provider
it has DNS servers Global wide and like
I said it has optimal locations it has
got a global Service or in other words
it has got servers around the globe
different parts in the globe and that's
how they are able to provide High
availability and because it's not
running on just one server but on many
servers they provide High availability
and low latency if the environment that
you're going to work on is going to take
a lot of configuration backups
environmental backups then you can
expect questions in AWS config a classic
question would be how does AWS config
work along with AWS cloudtrail AWS
cloudtrail actually records user API
activity on the account and you know any
HTTP https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any APA calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloudtrail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your Cloud environment on
the other hand config is an a point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in AWS
config all right so with that
information you can always answer the
question what did my AWS resource look
like at a given point in time that
question gets answered when we use AWS
config on the other hand with cloudtrail
you can answer the question I mean by
looking at the cloud trail or with the
help of cloudtrail you can easily answer
the question who made an APA call to
modify this resource that's answered by
cloudflail and with cloudtrail we can
detect if security group was incorrectly
configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happened to be
a downtime and you want to identify who
made that change in the environment you
can simply look at cloudtrail and find
out who made the change and if you want
to look at how the environment looks
like before the change you can always
look at AWS config can AWS configure or
AWS config aggregate data across
different AWS accounts yes it can now
this question is actually to test
whether you have used AWS config or not
I know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability Zone specific some of them
are Regional specific and some of them
are Global Services in Amazon and though
some of the services are region Services
you still can do some changes you know
add some configuration to it and collect
Regional data in it for example S3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an S3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
Cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to cloudwatch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
Global by default but you can do some
changes and make it Global similarly AWS
config is a service that's a
region-based service but still you can
make it act globally we can aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts in an AWS config and
deliver the updates from different
accounts to one S3 bucket and can access
it from there AWS config also works or
integrates seamlessly with SNS topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
all right so whether you know that fact
or not the interviewer wants to
understand how well you know that fact
by asking this question how are reserved
instances different from on-demand DB
instances reserved instances and
on-demand instances are exactly the same
when it comes to their function but they
only differ based on how they are built
reserved instances are purchased for one
year or three year reservation and in
return we get a very low per hour
pricing because we're paying up front
it's generally said that reserved
incidence is 75 percentage cheaper than
on-demand instance and Amazon gives you
that benefit because you know you're
committing for one year and sometimes
you're paying in advance for the whole
year on the other hand on-demand
instances are built on an hourly hourly
price talking about Auto scaling how
will you understand the different types
of Auto scaling the interviewer might
ask this question which type of scaling
would you recommend for RDS and why the
two types of scaling as you would know
now vertical and horizontal and in
vertical scaling we can vertically scale
up the master database with a couple of
clicks all right so that's vertical
scaling vertical scaling is keeping the
same node and making it bigger and
bigger if previously it was running on
T2 micro now we would like to run it on
M3 two times large instance previously
it had one virtual CPU one gigabit now
it's gonna have eight virtual CPU and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand the horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one VM now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 VMS right
that's horizontal scaling so database
can only be scaled vertically and there
are 18 different types of instances we
can resize our rds2 right so this is
true for RDS MySQL postgres SQL mariadb
or local Microsoft SQL servers there are
18 type of instances we can vertically
scale up to on the other hand horizontal
scaling are good for replicas so they
are read-only replicas we're not going
to touch the master database we're not
going to touch the primary database but
I can do horizontal scaling only with
Amazon Aurora and I can add additional
read replicas I can add up to 15 Read
replicas for Amazon Aurora and up to
five a read replicas for RDS MySQL
postgres SQL and Murray DB RDS instances
and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right I read only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide that between vertical and
horizontal scaling if you're looking
into increase the storage and the
processing capacity we'll have to do a
vertical scaling if you are looking at
increasing the performance or of the
read heavy database we need to be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment still talking
about database this is another good
question you can expect in the interview
what is a maintenance window and Amazon
RDS will your DB instance be available
during the maintenance event all right
so this is really to test how well you
have understood the SLA how well you
have understood the Amazon rdas the
failover mechanism of Amazon rdas stuff
like that so RDS maintenance window it
lets you decide when a DB instance
modification a database engine upgrades
or software patching has to occur and
you you actually get to decide should it
happen at 12 in the night or should it
happen at afternoon should it happen
early in the morning should it happen in
the evening you actually get to decide
an automatic scheduling by Amazon is
done only for patches that are security
and durability related sometimes Amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the DB
instance will be available during that
event because you're going to have
primary and secondary right so when that
upgrade happens Amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach consistency within a
second and sometimes when you write and
when you're you know trying to read
immediately chances that you you would
still be reading the old data that's
eventual consistent C on the other hand
there is another consistency model
called the strong consistency or
strongly consistent read where there is
going to be a delay in writing the data
you know making sure the data is written
in all places but it guarantees one
thing that is once you have done a write
and then you're trying to do a read it's
going to make sure that it's going to
show you the updated data not the old
data now you can be guaranteed of it
that it is going to show the updated
data and not the old data that's
strongly consistent still talking about
database talking about nosql dynamodb or
nosql database which is dynamodb in
Amazon you could be asked this question
what kind of query functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides a flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using Global secondary in tax
and local secondary indexes a primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite partition
sort key in other words a dynamodb
indexes a composite partition sort key
as a partition key element and a sort
key element and by holding the partition
key you know when doing a search or when
doing a query by holding the partition
key element constant we can search
across the sort key element to retrieve
the other items in that table and at the
composite partition sort key should be a
combination of user ID partition and a
timestamp so that's what the composite
partition sort key is made of let's look
at some of the multiple choice questions
you know sometimes some companies would
have an written test or an McQ type
online test before they call you for the
first level or before they call you for
the second level so these are some
classical questions that companies asked
or companies ask in their multiple
choice online questions let's look at
this question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have AWS step functions Amazon
mq Amazon simple Q service Amazon simple
notification service let's read the
question again as a developer using this
pay-per-view service so the service that
we are looking for is a paper or your
service you can send store and retrieve
messages between two software components
kind of like a queue there so what would
be the right answer it would be Amazon
simple Q service now Amazon simple queue
service is the one that's used to
decouple at the environment it breaks
the tight coupling and then it
introduces decoupling in that
environment by providing a queue or by
inserting a queue between two software
components let's look at this other
question if you would like to host a
real-time audio and video conferencing
application on aw yes right it's an
audio and video conferencing application
on AWS this service provides you with a
secure and easy to use application what
is this service let's look at the
options they are Amazon chime Amazon
workspace Amazon mq Amazon appstream all
right you might tend to look at Amazon
appstream because it's real time and
video conference but it's actually for a
different purpose it's actually Amazon
chime that lets you create chat and
create a chat board and then collaborate
with the security of the AWS services so
it lets you do the audio it lets you do
the video conference all supported by
AWS security features it's actually
Amazon China let's look at this question
as your company's aw solution architect
you are in charge of Designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar
which of the following service best
serves your requirement AWS ec2 Auto
scaling AWS snowball AWS forget AWS
batch let's read the question again as
your company's AWS solution architect
you are in charge of Designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar it
looks like it's batch service let's look
at the other options as well AWS
snowball is actually an storage
Transport service ec2 auto scaling is
you know in introducing scalability and
elasticity in the environment and AWS
far gate is container services AWS batch
is the one is being referred here that
actually runs thousands of individual
jobs which are similar AWS batch it's
the right answer let's look at the other
one you are a machine learning engineer
and you're looking for a service that
helps you build and train machine
learning models in AWS which among the
following are we referring to so we have
Amazon sagemaker and AWS deep lens
Amazon comprehend AWS device form let's
read the question again you are a
machine learning engineer and you're
looking for a service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in AWS which among the following are
referred here the answer is Sage maker
it provides every developer and data
scientists with the ability to build
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly that's what sagemaker does now
for you to be familiar with you know the
products I would recommend you to you
know simply go through the product
description and there's one page
available on Amazon that explains all
the products a quick neat and simple and
that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it the DB service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great confidence so the
answer is Amazon Sage maker because
that's the one that provides develop
purpose and a data scientist the ability
to build the train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible all
right let's look at this one let's say
that you are working for your company's
ID team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the AWS resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the AWS resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it Amazon VPC Amazon IAM Amazon
inspector Amazon elastic load balancing
Amazon VPC is a networking service
Amazon IAM is an username password
authentication Amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and Amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be Amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports PC
Xbox PlayStation IOS and Android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on Amazon's servers so
we have Amazon game lift Amazon green
grass Amazon Lumberyard Amazon Sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports PC Xbox PlayStation
IOS and Android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on Amazon servers the answer is Amazon
lumber yard this lumber yard is an free
AAA gaming engine deeply integrated with
the AWS and twitch with full source this
yard provides a growing set of tools
that helps you create an highest game
quality applications and they connect to
a lot of games and vast compute and
storage in the cloud so it's that
service they are referring to let's look
at this question you are the project
manager of your company's Cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your AWS
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have AWS budgets we have AWS
cost Explorer we have Amazon workmail we
have Amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost Explorer now cost
Explorer is an option you need the
Amazon console that helps you to
visualize and understand and even manage
the AWS cost over time who's spending
more who's spending less and what is the
trend what is the projected cost for the
coming month all these can be visualized
in AWS cost Explorer let's look at this
question you are a chief Cloud architect
act at your company and how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources so we have a cloud
formation as a service we have AWS
Aurora as a solution we have AWS Auto
scaling and Amazon API Gateway let's
read the question again you're the chief
Cloud architect at your company how can
you automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is auto
scaling right that's a basic service and
solution architect course is it auto
scaling is the service that helps us to
easily adjust Monitor and ensure the
maximum performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources it does that by
automatically scaling the environment to
handle the inputs let's look at this
question as a database administrator you
will use a service that is used to set
up and manage databases such as MySQL
mayadb and postgres SQL which service
are we referring to Amazon Aurora Amazon
elastic cache AWS RDS AWS database
migration service Amazon Aurora is
Amazon's flavor of the RDS service and
elastic cache is is the caching service
provided by Amazon they are not
full-fledged database and database
migration service just like the name
says it helps to migrate the database
from on-premises to the cloud and from
one a database flavor to another
database flavor Amazon RDS is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that helps us to
set up manage our databases like MySQL
maridb and postgres SQL it's Amazon RTS
let's look at this last question a part
of your marketing work requires you to
push messages to onto Google Facebook
Windows and Apple through apis or AWS
Management console you will use the
following service so the options are AWS
cloudtrail AWS config Amazon chime AWS
simple notification service all right it
says a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages it's
dealing with pushing messages to Google
Facebook Windows and Apple through apis
or AWS Management console you will use
the following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is a message pushing service and
sqs is pulling similarly as NS is
pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages to
Google Facebook Windows and Apple
through API and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service hello everyone this
is Samuel and I'm very excited that
you're watching this video and I would
like to welcome you to this Azure
interview preparation session knowing
Azure is one thing having worked on
Azure is another thing and being able to
answer interview questions in Azure is a
totally different thing although one
helps the other it's still different
skills and our aim through this video is
to prepare you with common product and
scenario based interview questions so
why wait let's get started a common
Cloud interview question is what's the
difference between SAS Paz and is we all
know that a software as a service is
Thin Client model of software
provisioning where client in this case
usually is simply a web browser
providing the point of access to
softwares running on the servers now SAS
is the most familiar form of cloud
service for customers SAS moves the task
of managing software and its deployment
to third-party services meaning the
vendor actually gets to manage all that
so SAS is software as a service
involving application is being consumed
and used by organization so it's
generally using an application and
usually organizations pay for their use
of this particular application now some
examples of SAS would include Office 365
Salesforce is another very good example
of SAS and a lot of Google Apps and
Storage Solutions like box and Dropbox
are a very good example of software as a
service talking about platform as a
service or paths it actually functions
at the lower level than SAS now
typically it provides a platform on
which software can be developed and
deployed now here we developed the
software we deploy the software now Paz
actually provides an abstract of much of
the work dealing with servers and giving
client and environment in which the
operating system and the server software
and the Hardwares the network are
managed and taken care in other words
with a platform as a service all the
things that I've mentioned like these
servers the server software the hardware
everything is managed by the provider
and we can focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
environments and some examples of pass
in Azure is SQL and Azure storage
talking about infrastructure as a
service I as now this is moving down the
stack even further now we get to the
fundamental building block of the cloud
service which is infrastructure as a
service is now is is fully of Highly
automated scalable Computer Resources is
full of storage is full of the network
capability that's what is now is clients
have direct access to the servers and
storage just as they would to do
traditional servers but in this case
it's going to be in the cloud in this
case it's going to be more scalable so
is very similar to what you would do in
your on-premises physical data center
but when we talk about is we get to do
everything but it's stored in the cloud
so if we need to build a definition
around is is or infrastructure as a
service provides users with components
it provides components it does not give
us a built environment it simply
provides a component such as operating
system a networking capabilities and a
lot more now this is a paid for based on
the usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of is in
Azure is a virtual machine that's a
great example for is and v-nets for
networking that's another good example
for is in Azure another common question
in Azure interview is what are the
instant types offered by Azure the main
intention of this question is how well
have you understood the different
offerings in Azure and how well are you
trained to pick the right offering for
the right service now one size does not
fit all and thereof there are a lot of
services in Azure that under the carpet
it does the same thing but depending on
how different your requirement is we'll
have to pick the appropriate server so
this actually this question what are the
different instant types offered by Azure
it's to test how well have you used the
product and services available in Azure
and how well have you applied them for
the given requirement you shouldn't be
provisioning more you shouldn't be
provosting less at the same time so it's
kind of matching the right service to
the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by Azure as you
see in the list we have general purpose
compute optimized memory optimized
storage optimized GPU virtual machines
and high performance compute virtual
machines now answering just the names
won't be enough in an interview you'll
have to go further and explain why and
in What scenario you would use general
purpose and what are the use cases what
type of servers is a good fit for a
general purpose and what type is a good
fit for computer optimized so on and so
forth and that's exactly what we're
going to do now so the general purpose
VMS you know they provide a balanced CPU
to memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for development
environment very good for small and
medium databases and also for low to
medium traffic web servers and some of
the use cases are like we said test
servers low traffic web servers small to
medium databases some Enterprise grade
applications it's also good for
relational database it's also good for
servers used for in-memory caching it's
also good for some small analytic
database very good for microservices and
if you're trying to build a proof of
concept for an idea that you just have
or just parked and this is another good
server for doing proof of Concepts
because you're not going to send actual
traffic to it I just want to show that
you know your idea works so general
purpose server is a very good use case
for those scenarios and the largest
instance size we can get in general
purpose is standard d64 V3 which comes
with 256 gigabit of memory and 1600
gigabit of SSD temporary storage on the
other hand compute optimized VMS have an
a high CPU to memory ratio and are very
good for medium traffic web servers very
good for batch processing servers very
good for application servers now because
it's computer Optimum mice then compute
means a CPU it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster CPU but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual CPU some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads gaming servers require more
CPU they run really well batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in a computer
optimized and by doing that we get the
actual benefit of the compute optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size type is
standard f72s a V2 and here we get 144
gigabit of memory and 576 gigabit of SSD
temporary storage in compute optimized
VMS in the same lines memory optimized
VM they offer High memory to CPU ratio
and that are great for databases
databases require more memory so it's a
great fit for a database and it's a
great fit for medium to large scale
caches applications that require
in-memory analytics so this memory
optimized memory is more so it's very
good for in-memory analytics
applications and the largest instance
size we get here is standard
m128m and look at the gigabit of memory
it's a 3892 gigabit of memory and look
at the temporary storage it's a 1400
336 a gigabit of temporary storage on
the same lines storage optimized now I
guess I don't have to explain to you
what storage optimized is used for you
might have easily guessed looking at the
flow yes storage optimized VM offer High
disk throughput and IO and are very
ideal for Big Data SQL nosql databases
data warehousing servers large
transactional databases and lot more and
some of the examples of the applications
that can be launched on storage
optimized are Cassandra mongodb Cloudera
redis these are some familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized and one
difference between storage optimized and
the other servers are they are generally
optimized to use the local disk on the
Node attached directly to the VM rather
than using an durable disk which is
actually an remote disk space now what
does this allow this allows for greater
input outputs per second or throughput
for the workload so that's what we get a
greater throughput a greater input
outputs per second is what we get and
when we use storage optimized and the
largest instance size available in
storage optimized is a standard l32s and
the memory is 256 gigabit and look at
the temporary storage it's a
5630 gigabit of temporary storage GPU
type VMS easy to guess at GPU optimized
VMS are specialized virtual machines
available with multiple gpus attached to
them now these sizes are designed for or
these VMS are designed for computer
intensive graphic intensive
visualization workloads that require a
lot of graphical Processing Unit
attached to it so in short these are
virtual machines that specialize in
heavy graphic rendering and video
editing it also helps with model
training and interferencing with a
standard nd24 RS which has 448 gigabit
of memory and 2948 gigabit of temporary
storage and the last but not the least
but the best last but the best is high
performance compute or Azure H series
virtual machine genes now they are the
latest in high performance Computing VMS
and are aimed to handle workloads like
batch processing analytic molecular
modeling and fluid dynamics a lot of
complicated applications in this VM and
this is the fastest and Powerful CPU
virtual machine with the optional High
throughput interfaces and the largest
instance size that's available is a
standard l32s which comes with the 224
gigabit of memory and 200 gigabit of SSD
temporary storage and a third common
question is what are the deployment
environments offered by Azure there are
two main deployment environments one is
the staging environment and the other
one is the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you are deploying
a web app or web app on Linux you can
deploy them to a separate slot instead
of the default production slot when
running them in standard premium or
isolated app service plan tiers now the
deployments slots are actually live app
with their own host name and at a later
point the staging environment can be
swapped with the production environment
so why do we need an staging environment
what are the benefit of it so the
benefit of deploying an application to a
non-production or staging environment it
provides a platform to validate changes
to our application before it can be made
live in the production environment and
in this staging environment the app can
be identified using the azure's global
unique identifier also called as the
guid URL and it's very very similar to
the production URL except that it has a
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment this is
the live production environment that's
serving customers request that's serving
the customer content now it can be
slightly different from the staging
environment in a way that the URL that's
used to identify the production
environment that's more often DNS
friendly name like the name of the
actual service dot
cloudapp.net that way it differs in case
of staging environment you have a custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloudapp.net but in this
case you get the direct service name as
the name of the URL so this is live
production environment which receives
and handles and serves customer traffic
another commonly asked question in Azure
is what are the advantages of scaling in
Azure the actual thought behind the
question is to see how much have you
understood the scaling how much have you
seen and how much have you applied the
scaling effect in the production
environment and have received benefits
in return so let's talk about it
advantages of scaling in Azure some of
the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now Auto scaling
is a built-in feature for the cloud
services be it AWS Azure Google and
couple of other cloud service providers
it's a built-in feature for a cloud
service a cloud service should be Auto
scalable and that includes mobile
services virtual machines and when we
run our applications on mobile services
or virtual machines the website actually
gets the best performance during the
change in the demand again a different
applications might require different
performance needs for example for some
apps the performance measured based on
memory and another a good example is the
fluctuating demand for example you could
have a web app that handles millions of
requests during the day and literally
nothing at the night and auto scaling
this environment Auto scaling any of
these environment will automatically
automatically scale or fatten your
environment so to receive the all the
incoming traffic and during lean period
it actually gets Slimmer and Slimmer so
to help you with the cost so it actually
maximizes the performance that's what
Auto scaling does and like we said Auto
scaling scales up and scales Down based
on demand it not only scales up but also
scales down so to help you with the cost
and if you know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive traffic then we can very well go
ahead and schedule scaling to our
application or schedule scaling that
infrastructure based on time if we
already know that Monday to Friday
that's the traffic that I would get and
it's a constant one it's not a public
facing but you know it's an internal
application so I know all the 500 users
or the Thousand or the 5000 users who
will be using it so at any given point
it's just 5000 users it's not going to
go beyond that and during Saturday and
Sunday literally nobody is going to be
in office so no load at all so in that
case I pretty much know how the pattern
is going to be I can go for scheduled
scaling if I know at the pattern and
auto scaling like you said not only
helps with keeping the application
highly available it also helps with the
cost effectiveness of our infrastructure
so anytime there's a VM or a group of
VMS running on less CPU Auto scaling is
going to actually get the environment
Slimmer and Slimmer so we're not
unnecessarily running any resources and
paying for it if you're being
interviewed for the infra site in Azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are Windows Active
Directory and Azure active directory
different let's talk about the Windows
Active Directory first the non-cloud
Windows Active Directory was the service
was released along with Windows 2000
server Edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computer errors and lot
more it provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and a lot of
other on-premises resources that's what
the basic non-cloud active directory
does on the other hand the Azure active
directory is not designed to manage a
web-based Services the Azure active
directory on the other hand was designed
to support web-based services that use
rest API interfaces for Office 365
salesforce.com Etc unlike the plain
active directory this uses an completely
different protocol so protocol wise it's
different and the services that it
support is quite different now besides
that it also has couple of other
differences as well and let's look at
them so the actual active directory or
the windows actual directory is a
directory service that facilitates
working with interconnected complex and
different network resources in a very
unified manner on the other hand Azure
active directory is Microsoft's
multi-tenant cloud-based directory and
identity management service and the
Windows Active Directory has five layers
to store data to store user details and
to issue the management certifications
on the other hand Azure active directory
integrates or compresses the five layers
into just two layers here Windows Active
Directory works with on-premises servers
like applications file servers and
printers Etc on the other hand Azure
active directory it works on web-based
services that use restful interfaces if
you're being hired for the development
environment or for the cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment you might
find yourself being asked this question
what are the types of cues offered by
Azure now Azure supports two types of
queue mechanism the storage queue and
the service bus queue Let's Talk About
Storage queue first now the storage
queue which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple rest
based interface simple rest based get
put and Peak interface it provides
reliable persistent messaging within and
between other services it follows the
pub sub model or a pub sub messaging
infrastructure and it's best suited for
users that need to store more than 80
gigabit of messages in the queue it can
provide a logs for all the transactions
executed against the user's queue so
that's what we get with storage queue
and on the other hand service bus queue
the service bus queues are built on top
of broader messaging infrastructure and
they are designed to integrate
applications and applications component
that can span multiple communication
protocols so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span money multiple
communication protocols and even
different totally different network
environments so in short these service
buses are the service bus queues in
Azure are part of azure's messaging
infrastructure and they integrate
applications or application components
that can actually span multiple
different protocols and multiple
different network environments it also
provides an first and first out style
for delivery and the user's queue size
has to remain under 80 gigabits another
familiar question is what are the
advantages of azure resource manager now
the resource manager helps us to manage
at the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you tested how well
have you used resource manager and have
gotten the benefit of it this question
actually tests how easy it has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to when doing
deployments or when provisioning
resources without the resource manager
so let's get it into to the answers for
the question what are the advantages of
azure resource manager the in-shared
resource manager is called arm so the
arm helps deploy manage and monitor all
the resources for an application a
solution or a group so all the
interconnected application all the
interconnected Services can be monitored
as group using resource manager and a
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account I can
have like 10 different resources created
by resource manager or a resource Group
created by resource managers and I can
allow deny connection to those services
or only to those Services based on
whether the user should be accessing one
and not accessing the other so that way
it becomes easy to give access to a
group of application it helps in getting
billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like like that so
those details can be obtained using
Azure zos manager and provisioning
resources is made much easier with the
help of this resource manager another
question is how has integrating hybrid
Cloud been useful for Azure well with
the use of hybrid Cloud we get the best
of both the worlds so what's hybrid
Cloud it's nothing but combining the
public cloud and the private cloud and
allowing data and applications to be
shared between them so whenever the
compute or the processing demand
fluctuates hybrid cloud computing gives
businesses the ability to seamlessly
scale their on-premises infrastructure
in the public cloud and handle any kind
of
overflow in the requirement or overflow
in handling the application so it really
helps it helps it boost the productivity
of our on-premises application so with
the hybrid Cloud we get a greater
efficiency with combination of azure
services at devops process and tools for
the application running in on-premises
and by having a hybrid Cloud environment
users can take advantage of a constantly
updated Azure service and other AWS
Marketplace applications for their
on-premises environment and the other
benefit is with hybrid Cloud environment
we can simply deploy applications
regardless of its locations in case of
on-premises we'll have to worry about
the location but when we expand our
on-premises environment in the cloud and
they can or we can pick any of the
locations and simply deploy it in them
and this enables the applications to be
created at a greater speed what's
federating in Azure SQL now this
question is very specific about SQL how
can we scale the SQL database now this
is a very good question or a valid
question or an important question in the
interview because many customers or
companies have not been able to meet the
user demand because they could not scale
out the databases the theory of scaling
out or adding servers to accommodate the
increased workflows and traffic is not
hard to understand but the implications
can be very complicated the implications
can be very expensive we're well aware
of scaling the web service that's very
common but how do we scale the database
so Microsoft provides the tools and
Technologies so we can scale out the
database in the cloud and that's what is
called SQL or Federation in Azure SQL so
the way we scale out the SQL database is
by sharing sharing the database so
sharing actually enables users to take
advantages of the resources in the cloud
not only that it allows users to have
their own database or shared database
amongst each other because we're
creating a highly available database
because we're having shards in a
database it actually reduces the
possibility of a single point of failure
for our database and more importantly
because we're sharing because we're
using Federation and Azure SQL it
provides an cost effective scaling of
our databases by using Cloud resources
or by using billing only for the cloud
resources that we have used so no
pre-provisioning no over provisioning it
Provisions the right amount and we pay
the right amount let's talk about this
one what are the different types of
storage offered by Azure now the
different types of storage offered by
Azure are as you already know and as you
can see they are Azure blob storages
table storages file storage and queue
storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and
binary data and Azure blob storage is a
Microsoft's object storage solution for
the cloud now lab storage is optimized
for storing massive massive amount of
structured data that can be in form of
text or or in form of binary data so in
short blob storage enables users to
store unstructured data and those data
can be in the format of pictures music
video files and lot more and it stores
them along with their metadata and
another advantage or another feature
benefit that we get from blob storage is
when object is changed it is verified to
ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
user's storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an URL or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with The Blob
storage table storage on the other hand
is an a nosql store for schema Less
storage of secured data now this Azure
table storage is a service that stores
structured nosql data in the cloud and
because this table is email list it's
very easy to save your data it's very
easy to adapt your data as the need for
your application grows and this table
storage is very fast and cost effective
for many type of applications so some of
the some of the type of data that we can
store is table storage is good for
flexible databases like user data for
web applications address book storage
device information storage and if you
want to store metadata this is a very
good use case to store them in Azure
table storage Azure files is another
storage here it's an managed file share
for cloud or on-premises deployment so
file storage provides a file sharing
capabilities accessible by the server
messaging block protocol and this can be
accessed from the cloud and this can be
accessed from on-premises as well now
here in file storage the data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and https are
protocols and the more important thing
is azure takes care of managing hardware
and the operating system deployments for
Azure file storage so this additional
file storage can be used when we want to
burst the storage capacity in
on-premises so on-premises the primary
and cloud is the secondary or the
extended on-premises storage so it
actually improves the on-premises
performance and capabilities for our
on-premises data center and then we have
cues Azure queues it's a messaging store
for Reliable messaging between the
application components so we spoke a
little about this in the previous
question so the Azure queue storage is a
service for storing a large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world via HTTP or https
a protocol and here the a single message
can be up to 64 kilobits in size and in
a queue we can have millions of messages
and the limit can actually go up if we
have not reached the limit of the
storage account so it's millions and
millions of requests that can be stored
in the storage tube or the queue storage
so the queue storage in short provides
message queuing for large workloads and
it enables users to build flexible
applications and separate the functions
one from another so one failing doesn't
affect the other application which is
running healthy and this Q storage it
ensures the application is scalable and
less prone to individual component
failures because they are decoupled
separate now it also helps in monitoring
the queue which ensures the customer's
demands are met so Q is a great place to
monitor or a great component to monitor
so we understand how much a peak have we
reached for a particular application
service or a container what is text
analysis API in Azure machine learning
now a text analysis is actually an
cloud-based analytics API and it
provides an advanced natural language
processing over the raw text and it has
got four main functions like the
sentiment analysis or and the key phrase
analysis language deduction and few
other things now what do you mean by
sentiment analysis now sentiment
analysis is from the logs from the
comments from the text commands that we
receive do an analysis and find out
whether that's an positive or A negative
statement now if it is a the API the API
returns and sentiments code between 0
and 1 and 1 is positive and 0 is
negative and then in text analysis we
have a key phrase extraction which is it
will automatically extract the key
phrase to quickly identify the main
points in that key phrase for example if
you're analyzing and text which says the
food was delicious and there were
wonderful stuff then the API Returns the
main talking points of that phrase like
food food is the main talking point and
wonderful stuffs that was a main talking
point so that's another feature that
this text analysis has and then we have
language deduction in text analysis
right irrespective of what you paste it
can try to gauge and try to align it to
the 120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so I can simply take text from
the internet and I can paste it and the
text analysis software is going to
identify the language and then can run
phrase and sentiment analysis on those
texts right so in short text analysis is
an API a set of web services that can be
used for text analysis it can be used to
analyze unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are General only
between 0 and 1 and 1 being positive and
0 being the negative sentiment there is
no much training or in other words this
is not as complicated as couple of other
text analysis softwares are available in
the market we can simply paste we can
simply upload the text and we can call
the service and it runs a sentiment
analysis on it all by itself let's look
at this question what are the advantages
of azure queue storage if you're going
to work in a development environment if
you're going to work on an environment
that Embraces devops this could be a
question what are the advantages of
azure queue storage now Azure queue
storage is built to flexibly operate the
applications and separate the functions
between the applications that run large
workloads so when we design applications
for scale these applications can be
decoupled so that they can scale
independently you know anything
happening on an application is not
dependent on an other application and
anything happens to a section of the
application will not affect the other
application because they are now
decoupled and corrected through the
queue storage so the queue storage gives
us asynchronous message queuing for
communication between the applications
irrespective of whether they are running
in the cloud or whether they are running
in desktop or whether they are running
on premises or on mobile devices so in
short this queue storage enables message
queuing for large workloads in a simple
and cost effective and a durable manner
talking about the advantages advantages
is it provides Rich client libraries for
Java Android C plus plus PHP Ruby and
lot other services getting added during
every new release from Azure and the
main advantage again is it enables users
to build flexible apps and separate the
functions for bigger or greater
durability again into production of
queues into our application it ensures
our users applications are scalable and
less prone to individual component
failures meaning one component failing
is not going to take the whole
application down right if one component
fails it's just that component that
stays fails the rest are healthy and the
rest are going to function it also helps
us to monitor the cues and ensure the
servers are overwhelmed by sudden
traffic a burst so how much do I have in
the queue kind of determines the traffic
for my application and it's the queue is
more I can always go and auto scale my
environment and the queue is less I can
always go and Shrink or make my
environment thinner so it can save cost
and anytime there is more data in the
queue I can Auto scale monitor the
metric and do auto scaling based on that
metric so the environment knows that
there are more data's coming in I need
to expand myself to handle that much
amount of data this is a very common
question what are the two kinds of azure
web service roles now a service role is
a set of managed and load balanced
virtual machines that work to perform
some tasks and based on what it's going
to run on top of it is it going to run a
web service or is it going to run a
worker service defines what kind of
roles that gets attached or that goes on
this virtual machines so we have two
types web role and worker roles the web
role is a cloud service role that's
configured to run web applications
developed on programming languages
Technologies and majorly they support
IIs internet information service and
they support asp.net PHP Windows
communication foundation and so on so
that's web roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application through the user's IIs
internet information service on the
other hand worker roles are roles that
runs up applications and service level
tasks which generally do not require IIs
so IIs is actually the differentiating
factor so in worker roles is not
installed by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process along with web roles
and do tasks automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and or doing some changes in the
database getting new messages from the Q
and processing and lot more you know the
work the applications or the work that
does not require IAS that's what this
worker role does again the main
difference between the web role and the
worker role is that the web role
automatically deploys and hosts your
application through is whereas the
worker role does not use IAS and runs
our application as Standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so Azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to hack
deploy and manage a scalable and
reliable microservices and containers
now service fabric also addresses some
of the significant challenges in
developing and managing Cloud native
applications and the problem that IT
addresses and fixes is now developers
and administers can avoid complex
infrastructure problems and focus on
implementing Mission critical and
demanding workloads that can be scaled
and that can be managed through the
console or from the single place in
short service fabric provides a platform
that makes the process of developing
microservices and managing application
life cycle a lot easier and the
advantages of service fabric is that now
we can produce application with faster
time to Market because all the worry
about the infrastructure is taken away
from us we don't have to design an
infrastructure all that we need to worry
about is simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports Windows it's
supports Linux not only that it supports
servers on-premises and in the cloud
with service fabric we can scale up our
environment to even thousand machines in
just a single command or if there is an
immediate need for thousand machines I
can immediately scale them up to
thousand machines that's possible with
service fabric now let's look at this
question you can expect this question if
the customer is running hybrid
environment meaning having some of the
applications in on-premises and running
some of the applications from the cloud
and for some reason when classifying the
application that goes to the cloud and
that stays on premises they have decided
to keep the database in-house so in that
environment a lot of customers do that
so in that environment this is a classic
and a scenario based question a client
wants the front end of their application
to be hosted on Azure in the cloud and
once the database to be hosted in
on-premises for security reasons or to
have full control on their databases how
do we go about suggesting a solution for
this customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use the v-net based point
to site VPN solution so all the
front-end applications will be in the
cloud and they'll be hosted in a v-net
and from the v-net they'll be connecting
to the database through and point to
site or VPN so the traffic and the
writings and the reads are not coming
through the internet but through a point
to site VPN link that's connecting the
Azure v-net and the on-premises
environment and this model or this
approach or the solution is best suited
for scenarios where there are only a
limited number of resource that needs to
be connected between on-premises and the
cloud this is a very common question
what's Azure traffic manager of course
we know more running applications on a
single server we know more running
applications on or or from a single
environment right the same application
is being run from multiple environments
within Azure and and we can be running
from Azure and on-premise as well so
multiple environments between Azure and
on-premises and a lot of customers have
such environment and if you are facing
an interview with such customer this
could be an ideal question what is azure
traffic manager now the Azure traffic
manager is a dns-based traffic load
balancer that actually enables us to
distribute traffic between Services
across Azure Global regions and by doing
this it provides a good availability and
a good responsiveness to the application
and this traffic manager it uses DNS to
direct client requests to the most
appropriate service endpoint based on
the traffic routing logic and the health
of the endpoints that it maintains so in
short this traffic manager is a load
balancer that enables users to provide
High availability and responsiveness by
Distributing traffic in an optimal
manner across the Azure when we run the
same application in different regions so
some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using Azure traffic manager
is it provides multiple automatic
failover options it also helps with
reduced downtime it also helps with the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
users knowing from where our customers
are getting connected from that's
another big use case with Azure traffic
manager let's look at this question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual Network and
now we need to move them or create a
separation between them how do you go
about achieving it so the question goes
like this you need to isolate Network
traffic among VMS in a subnet which is
part of a virtual network with little
downtime and impact on the user so
that's the given scenario and the best
way we can do it is create a new virtual
Network and move all the VMS in that
subnet to the new virtual Network now
this feature is not possible with a lot
of other cloud service providers like
AWS and a lot of other providers now in
those environments we might need to shut
down we might need to stop the VM create
a new VM based on the image and it's an
Hefty process but here in Azure I can
simply move the VMS from one subnet to
another virtual Network without needing
for any additional security like the
network security group I can simply
isolate them if I need to by creating a
simple a new virtual Network and moving
the servers to the new virtual Network
look at this one this is another common
question with respect to Azure what is
public private and hybrid Cloud so this
is really to test how well have you
understood the different Cloud offerings
in the market public private and hybrid
or at least the three basic offerings in
the market public private and have
hybrid Cloud now the public cloud is the
most common way of deploying cloud
computing applications and it has
resources like servers storage and are
owned and operated by third-party cloud
service providers like Microsoft Azure
Microsoft Azure is a very good example
of public Cloud so here every component
that the user is using is running only
on Azure that's public Cloud right let
me talk to you about some of the
advantages of public Cloud some of the
advantages is low cost because there's
no need to purchase Hardware or software
and we pay only for the services that we
use in public cloud and there is
literally no maintenance because the
service provider maintains the
environment for us and with public Cloud
we have nearly unlimited scalability
meaning we can get resources on demand
and can meet our business requirements
on demand and the public clouds are very
highly reliable because they have a vast
Network of servers and they ensure that
our application does not fail so there
are some advantages of public Cloud
let's talk about private Cloud now
private Cloud consists of compute
resources used extensively by one
business or one organization now this
private Cloud can be physically located
at our organizations on-site data center
or it can be hosted by a third-party
service provider whichever the case the
private cloud services and
infrastructure are always maintained on
a private Network and they're maintained
on hardware and software that are
dedicated solely for one organization or
solely for your organization so in short
private cloud in Azure is azure Services
being run within an on-premises data
center or on-premises data center used
by the user to host systems or
applications and some of the advantages
some of the advantages is it gives more
security the resources are not shared
with others so have higher level of
control and security over our resource
and application is possible and then we
have a hybrid Cloud now hybrid cloud is
the best of both worlds so it combines
the features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on Azure and others within
on-premises data centers so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in
on-premises and half of them would be in
the cloud and they will be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid Cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood the Azure products and
services and are picking the right
service for the need so the question
would go like this what kind of storage
is best suited to handle unstructured
data a lot of storage options available
and the requirement here is what or
which one would you choose for unstruct
structured data the answer for that
question is block storage because blob
storage is designed to support
unstructured data it works in this way
it places the data into different tiers
based on how often they are accessed
different tier means different
performance different performance means
different costs associated with it so a
lot of add-on advantages will we get
when we use blob storage for
unstructured data in addition to it any
type of unstructured data can be stored
in a blob storage this is not true with
couple of other storage options that we
have in Azure only with blob storage we
can store any type of unstructured data
and the data Integrity is maintained
every time an object is changed in the
blob storage and the best part is the
blob storage helps increase applications
performance and reduces the bandwidth
consumption and reduces the bandwidth
consumption for that application so they
are the benefits that we get for Block
storage and block storage are the ones
that are well suited for unstructured
data and that's what your answer should
be it's really an five-step process and
if you have worked and if we have done
some Labs some basic Labs with Azure you
can easily answer this question so it's
a five-step process first step is to log
into the Azure the second one is to
create an resource resource or a
resource manager and within the resource
manager you will be selecting the
resource and then pick the operating
system do you want windows or Linux and
within Windows what's the flavor you
want or within Linux what's the flavor
you want so decide on it and then
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the name of
the instance or the VM that we're going
to launch and the password the URL that
goes with it and couple of other
relevant information that goes gets
itself attached with the VM and then
select the size of the virtual machine
different size different types available
for the kind of application and for the
intensity of the application that will
be running on top of it so select the
virtual select the size of the virtual
machine review everything whether
they're good or not if there are any
changes required go back and edit them
and then come back and launch and your
VM is there for you to start working
within like three or four minutes not
even five minutes within three or four
minutes it gets ready and you can start
working on it so it's a quick and it's a
five-step process and you should be able
to answer it easily if you have done a
few labs in Azure let's now look at some
scenario based question you've been
posted with a scenario so we thought
through it and we picked some common
scenario based question that are being
asked in interview and I thought we'll
present it for you with the answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the the
correct and the best answer for this
would be using virtual Network in Azure
which enables us to communicate with the
internet securely which enables us to
communicate with the on-premises data
center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of using virtual network is
users can create their own private
Network users can pick their own private
IP ranges users can create their own
subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets a lot
more goes into that virtual Network so
it's very customizable and the users are
provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual Network that we own So within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines I and of course all
traffic stays within the Azure Network
Azure virtual machine or within the
Azure Network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up a
routing to go or reach the Internet it's
going to go otherwise it's going to stay
within Azure if you have set up routing
to reach on-premises then it's going to
go and reach on-premises otherwise it's
not going to go and reach on-premises
it's going to stay within the Azure and
it also allows users to design their own
network like we already discussed
picking up IPS picking routing you know
picking subnets you know how many
servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the IP ranges the natting
the masking of ips creating of VPN all
that's possible with the virtual Network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you Ensure or that every
time a user logs in they are not asked
to re-enter the password as part of
authentication so you really don't want
your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before they log in ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that no wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hassle free so they're not
asked to re-enter the password or the
same password again and again let's look
at the options available the first one
is to enable Microsoft account
authentication well it's not going to
fix because with that the user will
still need to re-enter the username and
password at deploy express route it's
not going to fix either because express
route is a network level service that
connects on premises to the cloud so
that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have set up VPN between
on-premises Data Center and Azure set up
80 domain controller in VM and Implement
integrated Windows authentication well
you can use the same username and
password for on-premises and the cloud
but this setup the VPN and the area
controller setup it's not going to stop
you asking for repeated passwords so
this is all about using the same
password in on-premises and in the cloud
and this has got nothing to do with not
prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right so that's same
password is different from not prompting
the user to re-enter the password there
are two different scenarios so that is
also out of the equation and the last
one is configure ad sync to use single
sign-on that's the right one so when we
configure the ad to use the single sign
on then it's going it's not going to ask
for the username and password every time
we access an application because we have
logged in and that login is going to
stay active for like 24 hours or so
depending on how you configure it and
within that time you can access a lot of
other applications and it's not going to
ask for the username and password
because you already have a single signed
on and you have signed in using the
right credentials let's look at this one
you need to ensure that a virtual
machines remain available while
migrating to Azure what would be the
appropriate service to use right let's
look at the options traffic manager
traffic manager is is literally and DNS
service and then let's look at the other
one update domains it again has to do
with traffic manager updating the URL so
the traffic manager gets updated and
then starts sending requests to that
particular URL it's gonna take some down
time because when we update the URL they
will have to be populated to all
different places and it takes time so
within that time any user trying to
access it's going to fail and then we
have express route and cloud services
express route could be the in fact it's
the right answer because express route
it's an extension of our on-premises and
Cloud environment and in this question
it really comes out from a customer
who's having an hybrid environment so
they have applications running in
on-premises they have applications
running in the cloud and they want to
have a way to migrate applications from
on-premises to the cloud in other words
kind of do a cut over between
on-premises and the cloud and this
express route is a service that connects
between on-premises and the cloud so
when you do the cutover the traffic is
now sent to the cloud instead of being
handled in on-premises in fact the
services and the application is getting
down or getting shut down in on-premises
so the request will come in the same
pattern instead of there being handled
in on-premises they are now routed to
the cloud using express route and and
the API calls get addressed or the the
queries gets answered in the cloud
through the express route service look
at this question you are an
administrator for a website called Web
game and you are required to validate
and deploy changes made to your website
by your development team with minimum
downtime so the real question is how do
you validate the deployment changes
that's made by the development team
let's look at the options create a new
linked resource create a staging
environment for the site enable remote
debugging on the website and then create
a new website well why would you want to
create a new website just to validate
the changes and doing a remote debugging
is not going to help because debugging
only captures logs of the changes
happening it does not do anything with
validating the changes create a staging
environment could be or is the right
answer because when we have staging
environments anything that we run on
production can be run on staging
environment and any failures that would
happen in production if we simply run it
in production can be captured when we
run the application in the staging
environment so that way staging
environment is a very helpful and useful
service and that way I can catch any
errors in other words I can validate the
changes that were done by my development
team before I move it to production and
that reduces the downtime in the
production environment look at this one
last question that we have for you it's
a standard tier application is used
across the world and uses Azure website
standard tier it uses large amount of
image files so you can get it this could
be an e-commerce website which has a lot
of pictures in it and this is causing
the application to load slow how can we
handle this situation let's look at the
options given configure blob storage
with custom domain well this application
has pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure Azure
website Auto scaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the CPU or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the CPU it's not the memory so
configure Azure for auto scaling is not
going to help and then what are the
other options let's see configure Azure
CDN to cache all responses from the
applications web endpoint a CDN could be
the right answer but look at that it
says a CDN to cache all responses from
the applications web endpoint CDN is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use CDN to
capture all responses from the
applications web endpoint the proper
design design for CDN would be to Cache
the frequently used ones in other words
cash the static content which are photos
videos logos and pictures and lot more
and static content that never changes
let's look at the last option configure
Azure CDN to Cache site images and
content stored in Azure blob storage
absolutely correct so here we will have
to redesign the application to store the
pictures high quality lazy loading or
slow loading pictures because of the
high quality and the bigger size so
store them in CDN and then the content
let it be stored in Azure blob storage
that's the right way of Designing the
application and if we do it this
application is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users well this was all
about the
YouTube also do share it with your
friends and if you have any questions
regarding this video then please feel
free to ask away in the comment section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here